Okarinasamase, partner.
And he's not.
A cowboy.
Howdy.
Howdy, fellas.
Oh yeah, I have a whip!
Oh yeah, baby.
Oh yeah.
This is Red Dead Redemption.
Welcome!
Welcome everybody, welcome, welcome, welcome back to Indiana Jones.
Last time...
Last time we were working and then a bald guy beat us up at the school and he stole some stuff.
He stole the cat mummy.
And now we're in Italy and we're dressed up as a priest and we're sneaking around.
Yeah!
Freak phantom with the whip.
Like snake?
No.
I say we're sneaking but we're not being super sneaky.
Probably.
Anyways, it's been a minute.
Quite a bit has happened since I last streamed.
And also, I want to address, last time I streamed this game, the game was like...
I can't, I can't play.
It was like, when I, so it's hard to, sometimes it's hard to tell.
When you set up, like when you set up and you're testing the game and it works and then you start the VTuber magic and you're just like, oh no.
Game plus VTuber magic, it's just not like that.
So I was testing some settings earlier and no matter what I turned on, what I turned off, what I did separately, like there were people in pre-chat being like, you should change this setting.
I had already tried it and it didn't change anything.
I was going through everything and so I was like...
And so I was, I was, I was venting to some friends.
I was like, man, this sucks, this game, what the hell?
And actually one of my friends was just like, oh, well, you know, you can, you got it on Game Pass.
I have a Xbox I don't really use if you want to borrow or if you want to keep it, like if I pay for it later, I don't know how much I'll use it.
But yeah, so that's, now I switched to Xbox so that we don't have to even consider my computer.
Yippee!
Get the Xbox mic too.
Oh gosh.
Mom said I can play for like five minutes before dinner.
It's cutting?
I'm going to play some Fortnite after this.
And then I got to do some homework.
I got to do some homework after this.
So after that I can only play for a little while.
I don't think so.
Where was my Waffle House fight?
We were right next to one and you ditched me.
I...
I was there.
I think you need to open your third eye.
If you can't see spirits.
Everybody shame Ashes.
Ashes can't see ghosts.
Wow, that's so sad for you.
Shame.
Oh my goodness.
What's up Phantom Thief Revenge?
Shoutout to Krisu over the VOD.
I played but I turned 29 yesterday.
One more year before I join House Gryffindor as a level 30 wizard.
May I humbly request a Metal Gear birthday song.
I think... I don't know if you'd be Gryffindor.
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Ghost of Mint.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, another birthday.
It's my birthday today.
I don't need a song.
Can I ask you to say...
Mint is one of the most awesome people I know that can achieve so many things.
Happy birthday.
I did say it.
Yeah, the concert was a lot of fun.
I talked with... well, Doki and I talked about it after the concert.
If you want to see more stuff that we said about it in the post-concert stream on her channel.
I watched back the VOD that Krisu uploaded.
I was so happy to actually have that kind of as a memory, you know.
Some little backstage magic, right?
Thank you for the two weeks notice.
What was that two weeks notice tweet?
No, it was about...
It was about Madara, my two weeks notice to her.
But I was watching back and I was like, okay, so here's some little...
So, you know, obviously for most of the songs we had the...
We had the...
We had like a mic set up on our ears, right?
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much!
And thank you for live streaming it too.
Oh my gosh, it was so crazy.
But...
I was like, oh, well, I want to have a mic for break stuff.
So I can like, you know, sing into it and like...
Into it and everything.
And I was like, oh...
So I had it for...
I had it for Triangle Dreamer and then also break stuff.
And...
But...
But it's very obvious I'm not used to...
Singing and dancing with a prop mic.
Because I had the headset on, right?
I was watching back and I was like...
Oh...
I needed to commit to the mic and I didn't.
Oopsie.
Double the mic, double the volume.
We would have never known...
No, I think if you watch back you can 100% see.
That the...
That it was a...
Barely take it further.
So happy I got to see everyone in 3D for the very first time.
Thank you!
Did you hear our special mix for Triangle Dreamer?
I didn't.
What was it?
It was...
You know, I had...
I could hear people, I could hear you guys.
But...
When there's also the music and the monitor and everything in my ears...
It's not...
It wasn't super easy.
Like, I could hear you guys...
When, you know...
When Doki was performing, but with...
When I'm performing...
It was...
Not super...
Like sometimes, if you guys were loud enough, I'd be like...
I didn't notice and I was there in person.
Ok, then don't rewatch it.
Because you'll really notice now that you know.
Because I would just kind of lose myself.
I'd be like...
And then I'd be like...
How did I just...
I'm not even doing anything.
Game?
I'm going to look back at it.
No!
Paying extra attention.
I'm glad you guys liked the concert.
I was so happy.
I think overall, even though I messed up a bunch...
I think it all turned out really well.
I was really happy with it.
Thank you guys.
Thank you everybody who was able to go.
I got so hyped when I heard last cup of coffee.
I actually wasn't going to bring it up that I was the one who suggested it.
I went to Doki and I was like...
Ok, crazy idea.
Feel free to...
Feel free to veto this.
But...
You know, I just thought that...
Like, I really liked the song.
And I was like, this could be a good chance to like, you know...
If anybody had any negative feelings about it, this would be maybe a good chance to have it become like a better type of a memory.
So, you know...
I was like, you know, maybe...
It could be something like that instead of, you know, if someone hears it somewhere for some reason and be like...
They could instead be like, yeah, I saw Doki and Mint perform that song in 3D.
And it was really such a fun and good event.
Yeah.
So...
Hopefully that's the way it...
Turned out for some people.
Turned out for you guys.
Mintboy!
Watched Chris's video, you were so cute.
Thank you!
I'm guessing you saw, heard Herb saying Snake Eater.
Thoughts?
I messaged her right afterwards.
I messaged her.
I was just like...
Herb!
I was like...
Snake Eater!
She...
She's so sweet, gosh.
I love her so much.
She was just like...
I almost said...
I hope...
Mint enjoyed that.
Thinking that I might be in the crowd.
And if you had a certain chill, maybe...
Maybe you also have a sixth sense.
Because I was haunting the concert.
So...
So proud of you, Minky.
Thank you!
Linkat!
Shoutout to Weben for lifting me during the Gachikoi Koujou at the end of Triangle Dreamer.
Let's go!
Yeah!
Yeah, it was a lot of fun, so...
Hopefully...
Hopefully I can do more 3D concerts.
Can you elaborate on the Lonely Island?
What do you...
What's...
Elaborate on what part?
See, it was for you.
No!
She said that she always wanted to sing that song.
That she knew I was a big fan of Metal Gear.
But I don't think she realizes.
Seems self-explanatory to me.
So, the...
Some, you know...
If you're confused about the ending lyric...
The ending lyric is...
If you had sex in the last 30 minutes...
You are qualified to sing with us.
Right?
And I just thought that the whole...
The whole concert...
Was...
Was the sex.
So everybody in the room...
Was able to sing it.
Why are you guys saying...
Why are you guys saying what?
What do you mean?
Hold on, my chat broke.
Hold on.
I have to refresh YouTube.
You don't think so?
Is it not like that?
Where it's just like...
Oh yeah, that concert was...
Was it.
That was like the sex.
And so, congrats...
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
It's the congratulations.
You know?
Does that mean there will be a bunch of wisp goons popping out...
In 9 months?
I...
I don't know.
The concert was so amazing getting to run in the Hamtaro circle.
I wouldn't say run.
It was like the Hamtaro trot.
The Hamtaro shuffle.
It was like if a retirement home had done the Hamtaro...
The Hamtaro circle.
That's okay though.
You guys...
You guys did the best with what you had, you know?
The concert was very sex, but also hung.
It's like you were meant to perform on stage in front of a crowd that's excited to see you.
Shut up!
Do the shuffle.
So rude.
What else?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just felt so...
I was reading everybody's letters.
I was reading them today and yesterday.
Realize you're 2k away from 300k.
Let's go.
Let's go!
I wasn't there, but...
Disappointment.
Yeah.
I was reading everybody's letters.
I was getting all emotional and I was just like...
Thank you guys.
Really appreciate it.
Wait, you can read?
Oh my gosh.
I got like some checkies from people.
Of like...
Some took checkies like during the show.
And like people walking before the show.
Oh my gosh.
Those are my like...
My treasures.
Oh, and...
I don't know if Seymour is here, but...
Seymour, he took some great photos too.
I got those.
Nah.
I want... If there's a... I don't know if they were...
The one with everybody.
Like there was a big group photo.
The group pic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was a really big group pic.
I don't know if because of the way that they...
Were shot.
If it was like, you know, digital or...
Or what.
But I want the group photo.
I was like...
I might try to scan it and then make it my Twitter.
My Twitter banner.
It's so cute.
It was Polaroid.
Because they're like really big.
They're really big.
And then people gave me some cute things.
I got a bunch of stickers.
And lots of cute letters.
And... Wait, where's the... Hold on.
Let me grab the checkie sheet.
Let me see.
The checkie sheet is so pretty.
It's so pretty.
Wait, how do I say this?
They wrote their name but they have fancy handwriting.
I can't read.
Grail...
Nates.
Grail Nates.
I don't know.
But it's the most beautiful checkie sheet ever.
It's so shiny and so beautiful.
I can't read.
I can't read!
I wanted to thank you and Doki for the show.
Not only because it was an amazing concert but because I got to meet so many Wisps for the first time.
Thanks for going Spice.
Bear hours.
Welcome to my worship.
Thank you.
I can't read.
But it's such a beautiful checkie sheet.
Oh my gosh.
I was staring at it like all...
All today.
I was like...
It's beautiful.
Heard you made Pia play MGS3.
And made Snake barf.
Yeah!
Pia and I, we went to...
We went to TGS together.
Wow!
Thank you!
Thank you for the Haka so far!
Great job with the concert.
Sorry I'm yapping so much you guys.
Don't worry.
We'll get into the game.
This always happens when I've been gone for a couple days.
I yap before I game.
But yeah, I love Pia.
She helped me at TGS with getting to...
She helped me at TGS with getting to the MGS booth.
And we walked around all together.
And it was just... She's just so sweet.
Mhm.
And...
Yeah.
Just got back from AW...
Are you... Oh, sorry.
Awa, according to Ina.
And had so much fun there at Phantom Thief.
I just got...
Oh, I got to make Wisp friends.
Learn about the gay and be in my first Samtaro circle.
Thanks for being around.
Binky, without you in this community, I would never have tried any of this.
Weeaboo!
Wait, that sounds funny if I just call you Weeaboo.
Because it seems like...
Weeaboo danger.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
New Wisp job opening.
Reading Wisp.
The reading Wisp.
Weeaboo.
But, um...
Glad you got our group Shikishi.
Yes!
Thank you, Tony!
Yeah, I got the group one.
It's so cute.
Thank you, thank you.
Samtaro circle never even made it halfway around the room, sad.
It's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Should really change that username.
Why?
Don't!
Don't change it.
Be proud.
You guys, I just realized I forgot to get more tea.
I forgot to get more tea.
So I'm gonna go grab some real, real quick.
I was eating frozen mango and then I forgot to get tea.
During off-kind next round, we'll send you some gift as a way to not be able to go to the concert.
You don't have... What are you talking about?
No, you don't have to send anything.
I was like, oh, I couldn't make it to the concert.
No!
Watched the bot at the office yesterday.
My co-workers were wondering why I went full...
Not knowing I had your...
Just a sick song playing in my headphones.
Howdy-meeto, Eric!
Hope you're doing well today.
You too!
Okay, BRB, guys.
I'm just gonna go run and grab the hot water.
BRB, BRB, BRB.
Fast.
Okay.
I'm back.
I'm ready to play Indiana Jones.
Oh.
There's your...
Wait, what's the previous one?
Oh, Ducky.
Thanks for the amazing concert and giving me an excuse to go to...
Awa...
Meeto.
Got to try Otake and participate in the Hamtaro Circle for the first time.
You guys have like the same exact message.
Got to see some Wisp friends again.
Yippee!
Ducky, why do you have like a signature?
Why do you have...
Like a wildest duck signature?
It has like...
Why not?
Orka, help me with it.
Was not prepared for the whiplash from the setlist.
I warned you.
I warned you that you guys were not ready for the setlist.
I warned you!
I got paid?
No way!
Break stuff was so good.
I felt really confident in it.
I was like, oh my gosh, this might have been the best job of me singing break stuff ever.
So I can't wait to upload it.
But I messed up, you guys!
You guys!
I messed up, I messed up.
I got nervous in saying the I feel like shit part too early.
And I corrected it later on.
I was so mad at myself afterwards.
I was like, no, I can't.
But I had to commit.
But they asked if I wanted to like...
Because they have the audio, right?
They asked if I wanted to have someone like edit it to fix it.
But I was like...
I don't know.
I think I should just leave it the way that it is.
But it just sounds off the whole time.
It worked in the end.
They were like, do you want to fix it?
I was like, no, I guess I'll just keep it as it was.
The finale song gets a lot of attention, but I feel like Junna's golden shower was way more unhinged.
You are 100% correct.
You are 100% correct in that.
We found out everybody else's setlist the day of.
I was like, what is this?
I saw it on the setlist written there.
I was like, huh?
Surely it's like...
Not what it says.
Who made the setlist, by the way?
I chose my songs.
And Doki chose her songs, obviously.
Pia was so talented too.
Yeah, Pia was so talented.
Phoebe was so talented.
Junna, despite the sussiness, was also so talented.
And then for some of the group songs, or for the duet songs...
The first song, actually, that we sang, Ii ne te iya, which we did an English custom version.
We do plan on wanting to release a music video.
Not from the concert, but we'll record and have it as a proper cover that we want to do.
And Doki got someone to do the lyrics for us and have it customized to us.
So it was really, really cute.
I saw some people translating it as, like, good is... good is yeah, or something.
But the ii ne kind of translates to, like, you know when you like something on Twitter?
It's like, that's what ii ne is, you know?
Like, ii ne is what you call, like, liking.
In Japanese.
So it's more like, that's why we say in the song, hit, like, hit, like.
So, it's more like, it's hard to describe, how would you describe it?
It's like, like it, yeah!
Kind of more of a title in that kind of regard.
But ii ne, of course, means, like, it's good, ii ne.
But, like, in this context, it's like, hit like.
Yeah, subscribe, subscribe, subscribe.
Exactly, exactly.
Press the ii ne button.
It's good, isn't it?
No!
Too sad!
Hi Minto.
Hi Daniel!
I thought it meant, in a...
What?
Please give a like and leave a comment.
No, please subscribe.
Subscribe, like, comment, please subscribe.
Yes!
Didn't have time to write a letter besides sending one from the community.
But it makes me happy to know you asked for it and were able to get my stickers.
Yeah!
Yeah, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
One thing that I got that was so, so cool was Imu.
Imu, if you're listening.
Thank you so much.
I was so happy.
So, Imu sent a letter, but also Imu is a fan of Ayami Mama.
And sent the tiniest tapestry I've ever received, ever.
It's like the teeniest, tiniest little wall scroll.
But it's of Ayami Mama's art, and I've never even seen it before.
I was like, when I saw it, when I got it, I was like, what?
And it's of Rem and Rem and Rem.
So I was like, Ayami Rem.
How I became a fan of Ayami to begin with.
So, thank you so much.
I have it hanging off.
It's so, so cute.
Thank you.
Was it lewd?
No.
But yeah, thank you.
So everybody gave.
Everybody's letters were so sweet.
Everybody's little presents were so sweet.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Back for more indie goodness.
Oh my gosh, it's already been 35 minutes.
I...
Oh, I don't remember how to play this game.
So I'm gonna have to remember how to play this game.
So...
I'm gonna do something real quick, because I think I turned up the brightness when I played before.
So let me do that.
I was like, oh, it's like kind of...
Hello?
Oh, that's filter brightness.
I'm stupid.
Where's the brightness, brightness?
Hello?
It's a tiny bit dark.
Yeah.
High contrast mode.
Can't tell.
Gamma?
Where do you see the...
Oh, edit brightness.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
I turned it like way up before.
I was like, yo, I can't see anything.
Okay.
UI brightness, this should be fine.
Yeah, that's good.
Okay, that's so much better.
That's so much better.
I was able to get one of my Ace Combat figures.
I sent you.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Shout out to the GigaChad that recorded with 3DS.
You guys, I have to remember what the controls are for this game.
There's so many controls.
Opens from the other side.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
This is...
Hold on, I'm just gonna...
Okay.
Okay, that's punch.
This is whip.
Whip it good.
This is also punch.
Okay.
Good thing we have our little hidey hole.
And this is also punch, so...
Left trigger, left button are both punch.
And then...
Right trigger is also punch.
Okay.
LB might be the block.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
LB is block parry.
Okay, okay.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
And then...
This is jump.
This is crouch.
X and Y, I'm not quite sure.
Wasn't there a way to see what our mission was?
Hello.
Oh no, I just realized.
Okay, I'm gonna go down a little bit.
Perfect.
What did the youngster say?
You ate and left no crumbs?
Thanks.
Can I climb this?
Oh, here we go.
I don't know if I should be up here.
Oh, I can take a picture.
Wait.
What am I taking a picture of?
Oh, RB.
No, no, no.
Equip, equip, equip, equip.
Nobody saw.
Oh, here we go.
Maybe they want to take a picture of this.
No?
What am I taking a picture of?
This?
Pizza.
Chandelier.
No, the chandelier is...
Maybe this.
Oh, window cleaning!
Cleaning!
Okay.
Indy is an artist and I just don't understand his craft.
Indy is an art...
Look at this orange.
What can I...
When can I expect my cheque from Indy-tan?
Flash...
Flash mesh.
Thanks for the big concert.
I got to show what I learned from the otage and mix panels at AWA.
By the way, how do you turn off yakai?
I'm doing waza spontaneously.
That's the great part.
You know!
Oh, can I put this orange away?
Okay.
Alright.
Put it away.
No, no, no!
How do I put it away?
You know what?
I'll just eat it.
Gosh.
Why?
Thank you!
Okay, you guys.
It's going to take me a minute to get back into the groove of it.
How do I get up there?
Okay, so we're trying to find another way...
around those guards.
Why aren't they saying anything anymore?
That priest is just always monkeying around.
Okay, and that's how you sprint.
Alright.
Very good.
We're all good.
I love seeing you in Phantom Thief.
Thank you!
The concert was so much fun, especially being in the crowd screaming and cheering my heart out.
Can't wait for Indie-tan to get started.
Why Indie-tan?
Am I...is this an area that I'm not allowed to be in?
I can't remember.
Can I...am I allowed here?
I guess so.
Okay, usually it'll turn red in the...
in the bottom left.
Bless you!
Hello!
What's that?
Do you think he'll turn around?
I wasn't grabbing for anything.
Thank you!
Kiss!
Oh, what did you hear?
He was coming at me!
I didn't do anything!
I don't know what you're talking about!
I can't go in here.
Okay, I'm trapped now.
I think.
I guess I go this way because I'm trapped.
Maybe over here?
Oh gosh.
Oh, we're fine.
Everything's good.
Oh, I can RB here.
Bless you!
Everybody's always sneezing around here.
Can I give to you as a video game case cover?
I heard you didn't have one of them, so I was thinking about...
You didn't have to!
You don't have to.
You really don't have to.
I think I'm good.
Maybe I can like...
And then I...
Oh gosh, everybody saw me fall.
It's so embarrassing.
My knees!
Limping Indy.
These priests, man, they just...
They're crazy now.
I think I'm back where I started.
Bless you!
I think we gotta go up through there.
Dang it.
Wait, how do I... How do I get around?
Oh gosh.
Yeah, I'm just a priest.
How?
What?
Okay, hold on.
Excuse me.
I have... I have godly things to do.
Okay, it saved for some reason.
Don't save!
I lost health!
We have to be careful here.
Not to get caught.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Alright, let's go around.
I think we went through that upstairs.
So I think if we go back through there, we can get through.
I'm getting noticed.
Don't perceive me.
No, please.
Jesus, take the whip.
We'll wait for when nobody is looking.
There we go.
Nice.
I'm crawling.
How do I stand up?
Get up, Indy!
No, no, no.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Up here?
Up here.
Nice.
Your streams are a great source of comfort and laughs whenever I'm having a tough time.
Chovek, you're being nice to me.
What happened?
You must be really having a tough time.
Are you okay?
Don't be angry.
Oh, man.
What are you staring at?
Just a... just a... you know, parkouring priest.
No big deal here.
Nothing to be concerned about.
This is how all priests get up.
Picture?
Wait, what's this?
There is some bread here.
Oh, my item limit has reached.
Where is the picture at?
Oh, wait.
The courtyard.
Oh, okay.
Everybody is a critic.
What?
It literally shows right here.
Oh, there we go.
They are tiny.
Little babies.
Do you think he's gone?
This guy is so lazy.
What is this?
I won't grab it.
He might get angry at me.
Zoom button where?
Indy would be less suspicious as a priest if he were wrestling...
for the orphans instead.
True.
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
He's not gonna care though, right?
I'm just a parkouring priest.
See, he's relaxed.
What is... what is that?
Why is that shining?
What does that mean?
It's taking my interests.
I'm like a bird?
I'm like a bird.
It's the fast travel spot?
Oh, that's all that it means?
That's kinda lame.
Alright guys, as soon as we enter here, we're in bad...
Bad.
I think I missed.
I think I missed you guys.
Okay, as soon as we're in here...
We're in a restricted area.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Picture?
At a time like this?
Okay.
Now is not the time, Indy.
Anybody around?
I might have to punch people.
Just saying.
Oh shit, there's a guy up there.
Okay, we're fine.
Just gonna keep going down.
I think I hear some whispering.
They might notice me.
Let's just keep going.
Opens from the other side.
Holy moly, this place is craziness.
There, it's your birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Wait, I heard a sneeze.
Happy birthday dear Vert.
Where do you pronounce it, Vert?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
That's the place I'm trying to get past, right?
Do you think they'll notice?
Okay, I think now I can go.
Because they're not looking this way anymore.
Oh, nevermind.
That's not where...
Nevermind.
Reverse, reverse.
Okay, so...
Why am I in here anyway?
I don't remember.
How do I grab things?
Is this still restricted?
Absolutely.
Oh yes!
Yes, the excavation site!
That's right!
Oh my god.
Oh no, this place is crawling!
Okay, hold on.
I have a map.
Yeah, I don't remember how to check it.
Wait...
No...
Heal...
And then I... I think it's B.
It's X.
It's A.
It's trigger.
Yes.
Nice.
Oh, cards.
Okay.
No!
Why is this a bad zone?
Why is this...
Dammit, I'm just a priest watching over stuff.
X.
No...
Nothing is going on over here.
Maybe he'll come in here and I can wham him.
Grab a shovel to blend in.
I'm just an employee.
Everybody?
There's guys everywhere here.
How the hell am I supposed to blend in?
Do you think I need to change?
Hey, I meant to love the concert.
Thanks AK!
The music is so indie.
We'll wait for this guy to go away.
And then I'm gonna go blam this man.
There's a black shirt disguise, but I don't think you can access it yet.
No!
Surely the DLC that I paid extra money for...
Will give me extra...
What's it called?
It's two.
I'm looking through.
This guy doesn't leave.
What sounds weird?
I think I did it.
Oh no!
No, it's not...
His face!
Anyway.
Comrade down!
And the crowd goes mild!
Nobody does a damn thing.
Nobody cares.
Perfect.
Picture what?
What am I taking a picture of?
This?
No!
My thing!
Where is my...
No, no, no.
Put it away.
Where is my...
No, I don't want my fists.
Oh.
Why is it in the wall?
Damn sword in this town.
What's going...
What am I taking a picture of?
Oh my God!
Where did he go?
Where did he...
Wait.
Wasn't there a way to peek?
Or am I crazy?
This guy is really stiff.
He's fine though, probably.
Alright, we're looking for Giuseppe, right?
Just gonna go wait for this guy...
To turn around.
Yeah.
And you're all by yourself, buddy.
Oh.
What was that?
Nothing.
I'm gonna take out this entire place.
At this point.
What am I taking a picture of?
This one?
That's what I thought.
Okay.
Nice.
Sixth inscription, we got it.
You felt that bonk?
Honestly, me too.
Okay.
He's kind of stupid.
Look at his hands.
Look at the way their hands are.
What if I just sneak up and...
Anyway.
See, that's what I mean guys.
Who needs stealth when you have this?
Who needs stealth when I can just knock everybody out?
Don't yell.
Indy!
Indy, what the hell?
We're trying to be sneaky.
Indy!
I'm just, you know, cleaning up the joint.
Swiss postcard.
Blank postcard depicting the Pontifical Swiss Guard.
Wow, it really is blank.
They're about the same.
I don't think these guys wake up, so I think we can just kind of...
Don't worry about it.
I said don't worry about it.
I keep changing weapons, by the way, because they have like a limit, you know?
And so I...
I am changing...
Money.
We're really just taking care of this area, huh?
You're not Giuseppe, right?
I sure hope not.
I don't know what he looks like.
Look at this guy.
He looks really... He actually looks so relaxed.
Okay, now I can freely just take over this land.
Basically.
Oh, what's this?
Guards list.
Giuseppe!
Giuseppe.
F.
What does that mean?
Wait.
F.
The sippy.
I'll turn it up a little bit.
It's quiet.
No, not this guy!
Hopefully he didn't notice all of them.
Hopefully he didn't notice anybody asleep on the job.
Stealth game says who?
The whole body count out there.
Are you also looking for the sippy?
It's a good thing Indy doesn't pee in lockers.
I think we can just take this guy out.
Are they all awake again?
Nope.
Find section F.
Cool.
Oh, what's this?
Grab that.
We got to go back to that lady.
What?
How did I miss this right here?
I'm a fool.
Anything else around here?
Some pots and pans.
Money?
Money.
I love robbing.
I'm being a robber.
Section F.
Alright, we're free to... We're not entirely free.
Sneak 100.
Indy, that man is dead.
Nice and easy.
Goddamn.
Oh my God.
I got an even worse weapon.
I am ready to destroy.
Do I go into the... Oh so that's G.
So we just got to find F.
I found it!
How smart am I?
How do they... Actually, how do they get down there?
Once you're down there, you never come up, apparently.
Or, once you're down by me, you never come up.
I think this is the easier way.
There's a ladder.
Yeah, I see.
I used my eyes.
Give me a second.
Look how many weapons there are here.
It's almost like they're tools for research or something.
That would be ridiculous.
Giuseppe, don't be alarmed.
Even though I have a weapon.
It's for our protection.
You don't think that's him, do you?
Oh, I was about to kill him.
Giuseppe!
Oh shit!
I have the...
Where's the cellar man?
Oh, cellar key.
Took him out in three hits.
No more work for you.
Go home.
Anyway.
Time to go.
He's an archeologist, guys.
He's not meant for combat.
Not like us.
We're combaters.
Wait.
I thought I heard someone.
Must have been the wind.
I was gonna see if we could go into any of the other holes, but...
Doesn't seem to be the case.
We are an archeologist New Game Plus.
We downloaded the extra, you know... What's in here?
Can I give you a hand there, buddy?
No!
Someone's talking.
Opens from the other side.
Someone still has lips.
Not if I can help it.
Was it this area over here maybe?
This is not a restricted area!
Drop the weapon, Indy.
Nope.
Nice.
I don't want them to get suspicious of me.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just a priest.
Opens from the other side.
Oh this looks like where we...
This looks like the thing we walked along before when we were trying to meet up with the guy.
I don't think we missed anything.
Bless you.
I'm psychic?
Perhaps?
What's this?
Oh yeah!
80 euros.
Let's go.
Can I use the binoculars?
No!
Money baby.
How is the audio?
I feel like it's very quiet.
I wonder if I can turn it up.
It is quiet.
Oh I turned... Oh wait, no I had them on.
Maybe I just turn this up to like 85.
Well, I do have headphones on.
We'll do speakers though.
It's all good.
Actually, I'm gonna do headphones just in case I hear them like...
Like if they do left right, you know?
Then I can know where somebody is coming from.
Just sneezed and then got hit with the bless you.
I know.
Is this restricted area?
No, we're safe.
Wow!
Indy, you don't want to take a picture?
This isn't a proper view for you?
Guy has such specific tastes.
Travel to Castel Sant'Angelo.
Do I need to go there?
My
bad.
There's like the journal.
I don't understand.
I don't remember.
You start from there at night, yeah.
Select.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you saved me.
Down there.
That was that area.
Okay, we know where to go.
We know where to go.
I can get down from here.
Perfect.
I was gonna say, I have to go back through that one area.
But I guess not.
Alright.
I still don't understand exactly how to...
It won't let me whip it from over here though.
Okay, I'm gonna go real slow.
Okay, Indy.
Drop.
Down.
Stupid.
We're fine!
Everything...
is...
so fine.
Everything is Gucci.
What's in here?
Where?
What did I stumble upon?
Tower of Nicholas V?
Find the underworld gate.
Oh, I just...
This is where I'm supposed to go?
I might be a genius.
It's not restricted though, so...
What's over here?
Hello?
Oh, camera.
My adventurer points.
Oh, so there was two ways to come in it seems.
Through here.
No.
There is one way to come in it seems.
Don't worry about it.
Any rare secret treasures?
Okay.
Oh, what?
No!
I was correct.
There were two ways.
See?
Good morning.
This is where... Hold on.
The post office, right?
Find the address.
Wait, then what the hell was I doing in there?
What?
I thought I found out where I needed to go.
Buongiorno!
What's the hot secret?
Why do you look at me like that?
Fresca.
Hello.
Come on, Indy.
You can at least try.
You can at least try to say something in Italian.
You clearly know how to speak it.
This room is freaky.
These are freaky.
I don't like these.
What's this?
Strange mural.
Yeah, the weeping angels.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's what they're like.
They look so sad.
I'm sad.
I don't have a maiden.
I've got a big key.
No one to open my heart.
What does this say?
What were you reaching for, Indy?
What are you trying to grab?
The candle.
No, we don't need that.
What's over here?
Did those guys leave?
Are you just going to let me wander?
Lucky me.
I spoke too soon.
I'm in the sewers.
Can I get back up once I go down?
Wait, there was a picture.
Sewer bridge.
Stinky sewers.
So disgusting.
Requires sewers key.
What are you?
Are you asleep?
You got the sewers key.
I'll make sure you never wake up.
This guy has to have the sewers key.
That guy did not have the sewers key.
Yeah.
Yeah, he'll just be a little discombobulated.
Exactly!
Alright.
I'm not a suspicious guy.
I'm a guy.
Oh, what am I doing?
Oh my god, come on.
He noticed me so fast.
Everybody knows though that I'm... or rather they're supposed to know that I'm a guy from the United States, right?
Maybe that's not... like that I'm visiting from out of town.
I'm an out of towner.
Oh, what's this?
Mystery note.
Angry note.
Do not throw coins into the sewer grate.
It is not a wishing well.
If Antonio tells you otherwise, he is a liar.
This is the Vatican.
Have some respect for God.
And for me, the man who has to clean up when the sewer gets blocked.
Kindly, Ernesto.
Greetings.
Poor Ernesto.
He's just trying to do his job.
Wait, this guy I think is a captain.
I leave.
Do anything!
Are
they throwing things at me?
I died.
Oh my god, he's coming this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's not a great day.
Actually.
It's a really stinking day.
Let's go back through here.
Actually.
Oh, if I go through here, I can avoid him since he's making his little way down the road.
Perfect.
Let's see.
Through here.
Is running illegal?
Just kidding!
This guy!
But the...
Place I need to go was locked.
Or rather...
Hello.
Okay.
I'm also conversing.
We're so short!
Isn't Harrison Ford... Wait, no.
I'm thinking of... I think Tom Cruise is not a very tall guy.
Screw this guy.
Wait, take a picture.
Am I taking a picture?
Hello.
Cobblestone workers.
Hold on.
I don't think I have time.
I gotta go.
Time to go.
I remember I took out some guys here before.
Good times.
Nice.
They're birds!
Birds have no respect.
I'll sell our key.
I'm in.
Shut the door.
Nevermind.
Who cares.
Stone fragment.
How about a vintage anime figurine?
Hold on, hold on.
Before we do, let's look around a little bit more.
Picture.
Hey, that looks... That looks like we can beat that in.
Oh, a strange inscription.
Nice.
Seventh inscription.
We're killing it, you guys!
Guess there's nothing else in here.
How boring.
What?
You don't want the pottery?
Oh, wait.
I lied!
If I...
If I were a guy...
$69.69.
You think it'll explode on me?
This is my instinct.
Actually, it kind of sounds nice.
Like an ASMR.
Am I good?
Okay, wait.
Hold on.
That is a nice sound, though.
Thank you for being awesome.
Keep it up.
Thanks, Yoshi!
Maybe there's a clue somewhere close.
Water!
I looked around.
Wait.
That's just some...
Clue.
Weapon.
Weapons.
What?
No clue.
Clue.
The cane?
We can pry it open.
Clue.
I don't want to grab it just yet.
Is there anything on the ceiling?
Isn't that the fragment?
Yeah, but I feel like it might trigger something, so I wanted to...
I wanted to get the chest open first.
You think it's...
I think it's...
8008.
I don't think it has any writing on it.
Um...
I don't know.
I don't see anything.
I really don't.
Oh well.
Disgusting.
The Great Circle.
Do you have any idea how old that was?
That's for the vase.
Apparently he does.
Wait, do you have a clue?
I put the money in the lockbox.
Pick it up when it's your turn to move artifacts from the dig site.
By the way, the captain changed the code again.
November lasts a year.
Oh!
Uh-oh!
Yay!
November... Wait, what year is it?
November 11th... Wait, would it be the date first or...
Let's try 3611.
No!
This thing is so sensitive.
Ok, 11.
Gibby!
Street Scrapper 1.
Congrats on the S concert.
Thank you!
I wasn't able to go due to work, but I'll def make one someday.
Yeah!
I'll see you there, Jay!
Yay!
Increase damage with one or two handed melee weapons.
Nice.
I'm the street scrapper.
99.
He looks so peaceful.
Ok.
Anyway.
Time to go.
Return the stone fragment.
Oh yeah, we gotta go take it to our friendly... that other dude.
Yeah, the professor.
Oh wait, wait, wait...
There was this here.
I'm gonna...
Bandage.
Use.
And grab.
There we go.
That other guy is gone, so...
Where do you see the...
Over here.
Yeah, we can go exchange some of the medicine bottles we've been getting.
For some groovy stuff.
Let's see what she's got.
Madam.
I can get some moxie.
Or moxie.
Or... moxie!
Or... shaping up.
I think I want some moxie.
I have just enough for the moxie.
Extend stamina bar and improve overall cardio fitness.
Oh, hell yeah!
So I sing at Event Horizon and the wisps were so hyped I had to go to the concert too.
Thank you, Serge!
Had a great time at both.
Thanks for the great show.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Maybe it was good advertising then.
Increase health reserve by adding...
I feel like I have... What is she typing on?
Ma'am?
There's nothing there.
This place is a little haunted, I think, you guys.
The devil has her.
I think I might want an extra health bar, I'm not gonna lie.
Because having only three is like... oof.
And then...
Increase health reserve.
So all of these are basically the same thing.
We've already taken a picture of this cat, but look how cute he is.
Hold on, I'm gonna get a really artsy picture.
This is so cute!
You are handsome!
She's a ghost rider?
Alright.
Sorry,
I keep opening it up because I'm like...
Oh okay, we just follow the little thingies and he'll lead us back home.
Alright, there is a guy here that wants to kill me.
But we'll just ignore him.
We're going inside here, I believe.
Hello!
Buongiorno!
Everybody is talking over each other.
We're in the right place, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Plus two.
What?
What did you say?
Oh, the ghost rider.
That is a good joke.
I'll admit.
You have the workings of a dad.
Indy, are you okay?
Do
I give it to you?
Antonio?
What?
Don't speak to me in riddles, weirdo.
Oh there!
I walked right past him!
Two!
Hold on.
I'm going to turn up the volume a little bit more.
And then I'm going to turn it down on my end.
Since I have it like extra high on my thing.
That wasn't a riddle, but it was his cadence, you know?
He was like, go to the tower of Nicholas V.
There you will find what lies beneath.
Sunday girl!
Thanks for the 8 months.
Speaking of cats, I'm glad Butaro is doing well.
Also, did Pies get mad when you left her for a few days?
No, she was fine.
Butaro is doing alright, yeah.
He is... For those who don't know, my cat had to get some surgery.
He had a little thing on his arm.
I took him to get surgery...
This... Wait, no.
Yesterday.
I was like, this morning.
No, that's not right.
Yesterday...
And... Does he have a cone?
He does have a cone.
He has a donut.
But... I'm worried about him a little bit because his arm or his paw has been a little bit swollen.
But they are saying that if it gets any bigger, then that's cause for worry.
But it doesn't seem to be getting bigger.
It seems to be not swelling.
It seems to be going down a little bit.
But he is my little guy.
And he has just been so grumpy.
Oh my god.
He has been kind of hellish to deal with because he has been so grumpy.
But I understand why he is grumpy.
Hey, I got your rock.
Professor, it's him who saved me.
Father Gallagher?
I say, thank you for rescuing poor Sidney.
Why are you poking him like that?
There you go.
My word.
You found it.
What do you make of it, sir?
Well, my bet would be it's a stone fragment of the epitaph from the tomb of Saint Peter.
You should have become an archaeologist, father.
It's never that adventurous.
Stop it!
Xbox, go away!
He is writing all over that book.
Stop poking him like that.
Why does he do that to him?
Marshall College Guide.
A guidebook concerning things of interest one can discover in Marshall College.
Oh, a map guide.
I was going to say, why do we care?
Alright, find the underworld gate.
Yeah, that's the name of the game.
What am I taking a photo of now?
There is so much... Wait, is it of the two of them?
Oh, that's so cute!
Wait, of him poking him.
Anyway, through here...
Is Antonio still trying to talk to me, but like all the way up there?
Like, calm down, man.
I'm trying to do the thing.
Antonio is just like...
Oh my god, he's still talking to me!
I can't, I'm going crazy!
This town is cursed, the devil is inside me!
I mean...
It's like I can still hear his voice.
Antonio, speak to me!
I wonder if he'll talk again.
Oh, I hear a cat.
I don't think it's this cat over here.
Actually, it might be.
Is our typewriter back?
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
This town is cursed.
This city.
There is something very devilish going on here.
Oh, that's the guy we are supposed to avoid, isn't it?
I'm just a priest.
Turn around!
Maybe it's not.
Or they are going to be like, you can't go this way again.
Just kidding.
Oh, it's that guy!
Uh-oh.
Yeah, that's right.
You don't notice me.
OK.
We are all good.
Into this room.
This freaky room.
Into the freaky room.
The freaky room.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Kiss.
What do you want me to do?
I thought it was like, you know.
A true love's kiss will wake him up.
Smash.
I guess we can smash.
Smash or pass.
Not that.
We can only use certain items.
Oh my gosh.
Where are all the items?
Where are all the weapon items?
Hello?
What?
Huh?
It won't even let me pick up a dang bottle.
Oh my god.
I thought that one was moving.
I wouldn't put it past Indiana Jones to make this kind of freaky though.
Can I borrow that?
We are being forcibly...oh wait.
Bottle of wine.
I was going to say they are forcing us to pass.
That is the thickest wine I've ever seen.
Rotate.
I sure hope I'm rotating it the right way.
Oh!
Now it looks like he is on top of the devil.
Explore the underworld.
It's not ominous at all.
Oh wait.
There was a candle here.
Nice.
We can't even go that way.
Where?
What?
Here we go.
The rats the size of horses.
Said those guys.
So how did no one ever think to do that before?
Is my question.
Like how did anybody see that and be like...
Oh my gosh.
Indy be careful.
I need to...oh this thing that looks like a sink?
Oh my god.
That scared me.
This thing that looks like a sink?
I'm just gonna pour something into it.
Oh.
Why is it so shiny?
Time out corner for you.
Can I light the candle?
No.
Ancient candle cannot be lit.
Oh this looks ominous you guys.
Did you hear that?
Press LT to raise the flame and see better.
Catch that.
Take this instead.
Nice.
It's sure looking ominous here guys.
Light that Indy.
Light it.
Indy.
Oh there we go.
Light.
Nice.
Oh zoinks Scoob.
I think there's some pretty gnarly things in here.
There's nothing in here.
Ok.
Oh.
Ancient technology.
The light in here was pretty cool.
Ok.
Let's take a picture.
This one is for the history book.
Sacred wounds mural.
Wait.
Where did my...
Let's pick that up please.
Oh the bottle of wine.
Hold on.
Before we do that...
I'm gonna...
Oh.
Just kidding.
Be careful with it Indy.
That works too.
Just be careful with the antique bus you know.
Wait.
Oh there's another picture.
Holy chalice.
And then this one is...
This one is walking on water.
Oh.
Ok there.
Sometimes it disappears and sometimes it doesn't.
We can't go in here quite yet.
What the?
I thought I heard someone.
I thought I heard someone go...
Like Naruto?
Exactly.
I didn't do the wine.
No!
What if I do wine here?
Oh maybe...
You know what?
Let's try it with the fire.
Pour it in baby.
Oh.
I thought I said H.
Two.
I didn't get the other one.
I'm an idiot.
I'm the worst...
I'm the worst archeologist ever.
I love...I love floor torch.
You don't want a picture of this?
This looks important too.
It's literal words.
Indy!
Come on!
Use that brain of yours.
Spear of Longinus.
That's what they call me at the club.
Open.
Oh wait.
Let's do the...
Let's do this again.
Ok.
Pour, pour, pour.
Avoid the fire.
Could be bad.
Use two-handed melee weapon...items to break down fragile walls.
What's this one say?
Three.
No!
This looks like a two-handed weapon.
Indy, I'm smarter than you.
Indy, please.
Alright, let's use our bottle of wine here now.
And it's a...
Five.
H2.
Again?
No.
No, no.
No, please.
I was worried.
What about this one?
This has got to be number one.
One.
See!
I knew this would happen!
We have to keep doing this.
Until there are...oh wait.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
So this one is...this one is three, the spear.
Ah, what the hell?
These are...ok, wait, hold on.
This one is...the chalice.
What is that one?
His hands?
Wait.
And then this one was...it was two and it was his body.
Body, yaddy, yaddy.
So probably this one, right?
Two!
Ok.
Or wait, or would this be the spear?
Hold on, what about this one over here?
This is him walking on water, so...
Oh!
It's got...
It's got like a...
Wait, why did it do that?
Go to the bottom.
It highlights which one it is.
Three!
Ok, so his left foot.
Or rather, his right foot.
His right foot, but our left foot.
So this one is three.
Three.
Nice.
And then...
This one is his right hand.
And it was two.
We got this.
Two!
Ok.
Left hand.
Yeah, but I'm going by...
You know what I mean.
This is his left hand.
But it's our right hand.
Oh, oh, this is not the right way.
Oh, I just realized there's that.
Ok, good.
Stage left.
I'm hearing a voice!
Sometimes it's like a...
It sounds like a woman.
She's going like...
Do you guys not hear it?
This one was three.
And then his other hand was...
This one was also three, right?
Double checking.
In the game?
Yeah, in the game, in the game, in the game, in the game.
Two!
Oh, it was two.
Good thing I checked.
Alright, two for the other hand.
The body is probably three.
Because of the spear.
And then we just need...
This one.
But it's over here.
Oh no!
I don't like that!
I guess there's nobody here.
Anointment of Jesus.
I got a thing.
I got a present from someone named Ryan who likes feet.
And Ryan did not decide to write a letter or anything.
Ryan decided to only send me some WeCross cards of Kiara.
Which is so nice.
But Ryan also decided to...
To write on the cards.
The first thing he wrote was on the first card.
The first card he...
The first thing he wrote was...
Wood.
And then on the second card...
He very erratically circled her armpit.
And that was the only thing...
Ryan gave me.
Four.
Okay.
Alright.
I feel like there was something else that he wrote.
Hold on, let me go grab it.
Least Freaky Wisp.
Hold on, let me grab it.
That's right.
He circled the armpit and just wrote... Peek.
Oh my god.
So good.
Make me laugh.
I was like...
Alright, this was four.
I figured it was four.
I feel like I could have brute-forced that, but...
Because why would they have a four option and then you never use it, right?
But...
Ryan is my goal.
Find the warrior giant's tomb?
I wish the game would stop spoiling it for me.
I don't know what I'm trying to find.
I've never been in here.
Stop telling me what I'm trying to find.
Wait, warrior giant?
Like the guy.
Wait, what is this?
Oh no, no, I want to take that.
Can't see anything.
Why is it like this?
Oh!
Front seating, true.
Look at all these little skellies.
Is this water?
No, I think it's just...
Oh yeah, there's a rat.
There's two rats.
Rats.
We are the rats.
I hear them everywhere.
The rats as tall as horses.
Oh, get out of here little guy.
What's this?
First room.
Oh, there's something in there that we want?
What do I place here?
What do you want?
What do you want from me?
That looks like a big old carrot.
Anything in here?
Really?
Nothing?
This tomb has not been disturbed in however millennia?
And we're just like, yeah, whatever.
And he's like, once you see...
One pot, you've seen them all.
Why did that turn red?
Why is this red?
This thing?
Oh, you scared me.
Oh, it scared me.
That's not good, we're in there.
Indy, we're in the thing that should burn down easily.
Maybe he means like the thing that we just took care of, right?
I don't like that once we go down there, it doesn't look like we can come back up.
Watch out little rat!
What's in here?
Let's go this way instead.
Burial chamber key!
Ancient burial chamber.
That looks in really good condition.
Found in the catacombs underneath the Vatican.
I don't think you'll be needing this anymore.
You could have just left, man.
You didn't have to rot away here.
What is...
This is the great circle.
It's very shiny.
See, this is how I would want to be buried.
I actually don't know what happened to my body.
This looks like a cozy blanket.
The dirt.
Oh my gosh, this place is huge.
Do I have a map or no?
Not really.
But it is also front seating me.
Outer Wilds.
This room is a little freaky.
Someone might know.
I feel like someone has to know.
What happened to my body?
And this goes up.
Let's go down.
Down into the catacombs.
Oh, it leads down here.
Gosh, it's dusty.
Oh, what am I taking a picture of?
No.
This?
Oh, the cross.
Jerusalem cross.
Sir, that is four points.
Okay.
Nothing down here.
Alright.
We are just being little adventurers.
Oh yeah, let's see.
My journal.
We can...
I think I can unlock some more books.
Shaping up.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Increase health reserve.
Nice.
Lucky hat.
Oh, that's right.
I feel like I should get that one.
What else do we have?
Wait, the fitness one.
Drains less stamina when climbing.
Combat.
Last hit before an improvised weapon break deals additional damage.
Increase damage with one or two handed melee weapons.
Oh, that's actually pretty good too.
Lucky hat, isn't that good to be honest?
Oh no, really?
A guidebook concerning things...
Wait, what?
Oh, that's just the... okay.
Why is that in here?
Anyway.
Hmm...
Lucky hat is good and cool when it happens.
Gives second wind but not much life if you're surrounded.
Ah, I see, I see.
So it could be good in maybe like a one on one fight.
Let's do...
I wanna do this one because I mean I use a lot of...
Melee weapons.
I mean I use my fists too, but...
Let's do this one.
And then I can also get lucky hat.
It's not so much expensive.
There we go.
Perfect.
Anyway, I'm just leveling up in the catacombs.
Finding my fedora will give me a second chance.
Why do they say it like that?
M'lady.
I've...
I've found new...
Oh, this is the... oh, that's so funny.
Journal page.
Paranoid writing.
Oh my gosh.
This person is a freak.
Harken.
I have become quarry.
For is it not footsteps and pursuit that I hear in the abyssal dark?
Heavy footfalls with a heavy cadence more terrible than mortal bend.
The giant.
Quietly they speak in the gloom.
What blasphemous words slip tween their lips I cannot say.
For it is not in the tongue of man.
Yet they refrain from drawing too close.
Seemingly content with observing the giant fiends of the infernal dark.
That's from 1152.
It's from a journal.
Medieval.
Oh, we can go through here.
Maybe?
Can we go...
Oh, I can and I'm scared.
Let's... hold on, there is other stuff around.
Like in here.
I think that actually just leads to out here.
Maybe?
Maybe it does not.
Actually I can't tell.
It looks like it for a second.
Maybe it leads to down here.
Yes.
So that goes back into this room.
Okay, okay.
So when we need to go back up we just go through there.
Boo!
Indy, where is your sidekick?
Indy!
I'm scared.
Indy, you have a sidekick.
Where are they?
Okay, nevermind.
We are just dusty crusty up in here.
It didn't look like we could go.
I'm scared of the night giants.
Back here maybe?
Squeak, squeak, squeaking.
Squeak, squeak, squeakerton.
Oh no?
No.
Where do I go then?
Did I miss something?
I mean, surely I did, but...
Surely I did, but...
Is this a little hole?
No, that's a grave.
Let me try going back through here.
There's something I missed, guys.
There's something I missed.
Miss, miss, miss.
Miss.
Maybe...
I used the ledge.
No, the ledge stops.
If I can use my whip, it will tell me, you know?
Made miss.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Three.
Wow, just in!
I just want to say that I flew down from DC to see the concert.
We had an absolute blast.
Thank you.
I hope it was worth it.
Oh, there it is.
Thank you.
My torch did not...
No!
I needed to burn this down.
You can throw it across?
Oh, I did not know that.
Okay, let's go get it.
Oh my god, this place looks super mega spooky when there's no torch.
I just throw it?
Turn...
My bad.
Little more oomph.
It's like...
Nice.
We did it.
Fire.
Why did they lock those up, I wonder?
That makes me nervous.
Why are some of these...
Oh my goodness.
This, I think...
Is a quarter couple.
Four!
Is this the tomb?
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
Hold on, there's a little bit more to explore.
A corporal.
Secret found.
This is it.
Tomb fresco.
Wow.
Oh yeah, look.
It's a...
Oh gosh, medieval art.
Just like those cats.
That's a...
Pig?
That's a man fighting a...
Dog?
Lizard?
Alright guys, let's go into the big baddie room.
Where we might have to fight...
These bones look...
Of average size, right?
This rib cage is just sticking up.
What is this?
Refrigerator.
Alright, here we go.
My hat.
Oh, I put my clothes back on.
I'm not a priest anymore.
I'm an adventurer.
Oh...
They were like, we don't want you being a priest for the cutscenes.
That's kind of nice though.
But what if I want to look...
Wait, Indy, what outfit are you wearing?
What are you wearing?
That's the right one, right?
Wait...
I need this.
Can I light this?
No?
Oh, I can light this.
Nice.
Oh, see, these are so scary.
Why do you look like that?
Even he is scared of it.
I'm next to that...
Freaky lady.
Face palm.
Okay, you guys made it silly.
This guy is hiding something.
Look, he is smiling.
He is like...
Oh wow, a knight.
Oh my gosh, he looks like the Praise the Sun guy.
Hiding his arm.
And his arm is actually an axe.
Why is that light on?
His arm is actually made of spiders.
Praise the Sun.
There is so much around here.
See, that's freaky.
Rain of spiders.
When do dark souls win?
I don't know.
I'm gonna try Bloodborne and see if I even like souls like Gims.
You know, I don't think I... I have to be super duper mentally prepared for the verbal abuse I'll get from chat.
I have to be prepared, I have to be mentally... I have to stable my mental fortitude.
We'll see though.
We'll see.
When... I mean like, Bloodborne is gonna be the same way.
But you know.
Chat, translate.
You can do it, Minky.
Thanks!
Okay, we're definitely gonna have to do something with these guys.
Eventually.
Alright, let's go.
Sorry, I was exploring.
Okay, let's go to the main event.
Elden Ring or DS3 are the easiest for an introductory game.
No Elp.
I didn't ask for your Elp.
Oh.
Tomb of the Warrior Giant.
Oh, 4 star!
I'm getting now why every game you play becomes a horror game, because it will always have a ghost in it.
You put a little boogie in it.
You get it?
No Elp.
I don't want your Elp.
How's the game's quality been so far?
Game is fine.
Where's the cross?
This one?
I don't know if you... Oh, Indy.
What do you mean it didn't work?
Crusader Shield.
Okay.
I know.
Silent Hill 2 moment.
I was thinking the same exact thing.
Of like when...
When he puts his hand in the toilet.
With the shield.
Put this here.
Nope.
Just kidding.
Why do I have this?
The one thing that's so funny about items in this game is they never look heavy.
You know what I mean?
Sorry.
That scared me.
They never...or rather they never sound heavy when you drop them.
Indy, your hand.
Oh no.
Indy!
Indy?
It's a big old boulder!
Oh RIP.
I guess that's one way to open it.
No way!
The barns!
No, Indy!
You destroyed it!
You are the worst archeologist ever!
No!
The barns!
What did you think giant...what did you think giant referred to, Indy?
What is that?
He doesn't care about the bones?
I feel like the bones are a cool part.
Fountain of Confession.
Entrance to the sacred monastery of the Nephilim Order.
This is when the baddies come in and are just like you found it for us.
I wanted this for my cat mummy.
Excuse me?
What?
No way.
The guy was just bulldozing through the whole thing.
What?
Oh no.
Indy move!
I don't think that's how bulldozers work.
Indy get your hat.
We got a trusty whip.
Trusty hat.
And...
I think you can push this.
I think you can push through that.
Whatever.
Map unlocked.
Necropolis.
What?
No I don't have my...
I don't have my torch.
Welcome to Vapusha.
Thank you.
8 months mogu's minted.
Necropolis.
Imagine it's like a weeping angel.
We turn the corner and he's gone.
I might...
I was gonna say I might poop my pants.
Luckily I didn't say that.
And it didn't happen.
Anyway.
I wish I had a torch right now.
Like zoinks goop.
I don't wanna fall in there.
This looks even worse cause it's really dark and it's also a dead end.
What then?
That was a bad shaggy.
You're a bad shaggy.
Uh.
I'm not even shaggy.
I'm minky.
I can't believe this female trying to impersonate.
The well known character of shaggy.
From beloved series.
Scooby Doo.
How dare she does a terrible impression of that man.
Okay.
I think we're just gonna have to drop down baby.
Let's go.
Thank you for one of the most life affirming concerts of my life.
What do you mean by that?
It reignited a passion in me to learn more mixes and why I hope you realize you healed a lot of hearts by convincing Tokyo to sing last cup of coffee.
Thank you!
Keep doing shaggy.
I beg.
Here we go.
Wait, maybe I do.
Oh no!
There's only one way.
Okay.
We're swimming through this nasty, nasty, nasty water filled with ancient bones.
No biggie.
Okay.
I don't know if this... Would this count as still water?
Like it looks like water comes in through up here, you know?
Otherwise there would be no sunlight.
Oh no, still water.
And up.
I mean I'm not saying I would drink it.
I'm just saying...
I don't... I'm looking.
There's not even fish in here.
I sure wish I had my torch.
Yeah, we are.
Camera.
Here?
There.
Oceanus.
That's sick.
That's a really cool picture.
I'll do 50.
No, we'll do 70.
Yeah, there's other people there.
Oh, I'm so sorry!
Oh, there are other guys.
Oh, my bad.
Yeah, 80 points for that.
I know, right?
Crazy.
Let's go.
Where's the exit, he says.
Just like the little ghosts.
I mean the skellies that are just kind of chilling around.
I feel like this is... Seems close to the surface.
With how the light is shining through.
How has nobody discovered this yet?
Yeah.
Don Liz, welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you!
Ancient anime figurines.
Alright, through here.
That was scary.
Yeah, maybe.
Hopefully.
Noseless.
Couldn't be me.
Oh, they have found it.
A ghost.
This isn't...
Oops, I meant to do this and then this.
This isn't a restricted area.
Yeah,
I'm fine.
I'm just a guy.
Oh, maybe I'm not supposed to be here.
Maybe I'm not supposed to be here.
Is there any weapons?
Anything about?
Oh, she'll...
Yeah.
Square up.
He's gonna notice his friend down.
And then I'm gonna bonk him.
Yeah, dummy!
Oh, I can get my own helmet?
Wait, how do I grab this?
Wait.
Bandage.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
He's a medic.
And a torch!
Why wouldn't a priest be able to be down here?
What's wrong with that?
I'm just...
I don't know.
I'm doing my duties.
He's a holy man.
Yeah, for some reason it was still considered a part of his body.
The helmet.
Okay.
Onwards.
I fear that I might explore too much sometimes, but...
I don't wanna miss out on...
No, not yet, Indy!
I don't wanna miss out on stuff.
What was that?
Okay, that's just a loopy loop.
It's like there was that one room...
There was a thing hidden behind...
There was one room we missed a note in.
It's frustrating.
You think our thing is gonna go out?
Yep.
Whoa.
Stop, Indy!
You're embarrassing me!
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Another baby puzzle.
Light?
Can I put this away?
Can I throw it through the hole?
Close.
Throw.
Scooch.
Damn.
Oh, wait!
Indy, I need you to get that back for me!
Indy!
Indy, I need you to get that back for
me!
Where did the other one go?
Oh.
There's gonna be more guys.
Surely.
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
Why didn't you say...
Minto, I think it will go out and you won't be able to get it back if you throw it in there.
Why didn't you stop me?
Indy!
Oh, please feed me.
I'm just a little hungry squirrel, madam.
May I please have a grape?
Oh, please.
No help.
Is this where I needed to throw it?
There's gonna be more guys.
This is me.
That's me after I threw...
That's me after I threw the damn thing.
Reload save.
Where was my last checkpoint?
Five minutes ago.
We just gotta knock these guys out again.
Easy peasy.
Ok, we got this.
We got this.
Literally through.
I know I wasn't softlocked, but I still wanted to get that part.
It's all good.
We wait for them to come over here.
In a thousand years, maybe I'll be worth something.
They clearly don't care about skellies.
You see this?
Indiana Jones sees a skeleton and he's just like, I don't care.
Poor thing.
Felt like a leaf.
Time to go after your friend.
This shadow is so ominous.
Where's your friend at?
Oh here he comes.
I see the light.
It's coming closer.
Yeah, you're bored huh?
I'll liven things up for you.
With a little...
Hey, where are you?
Hey, stop blocking.
Wait, you went down so easily before.
What happened?
We ragdolled him.
Nice, another medic.
So true.
Hey, give me your bandage.
Thank you.
Anyway, good day fellas.
And then we have now also the second one.
Because I lost the other one since I used it in combat.
Okay, here I imagine.
That's where I throw it, right?
Throw!
War crimes!
Oh,
I guess I can also...
Maybe I was soft locked.
Ancient relic.
Curious hand carved stone object of prehistoric origin.
This looks like literally everything else we've seen in this entire place.
I was going to say, I guess we can just throw it back through the hole.
But whatever.
Yeah, baby.
Nothing to swing across, so I guess we go down.
Oh, there's two of them.
There's two guys.
Three guys.
Four guys.
Why do they keep multiplying?
You can pretty much return almost anywhere you want after a mission, so no stress about missing stuff permanently.
Oh, really?
Thank you, Jesse.
Bless you.
Someone heard.
Someone is seeing.
Someone is perceiving.
No one perceives.
No one sees.
Drop this guy.
I don't care.
Pick up my weapon.
Oh gosh, this place is crawling.
Oh, there's another guy.
Oh my gosh.
It's like seven guys.
We need to open a new restaurant.
What if I threw this?
No.
Oh, it's a double handed.
Oh, there they are.
Just gonna do what I did before.
Oh, he's still alive.
How are you still awake?
Fascist whistling.
Yeah, we're not listening.
Oh.
Guy does not care at all.
I didn't even take damage.
Oh, I have another bat.
Wait, who?
Who noticed?
Oh, there's two guys up there.
I love not needing stealth.
I'm just going through.
Oh, wait.
Why are you...what?
Why are you over there?
What are you doing here?
Little whistle man.
That was weird, huh?
Peaceful.
I'm just exploring.
I love my fists.
I love having fists.
Oh, shit.
This guy's got a bat.
Anybody else over here?
No, I don't see any.
Yeah, I guess there were some other guys.
I can take them.
Three guys?
I can't take them.
They keep multiplying.
Isn't there supposed to be a guy that like wanders around up here?
Oh, wait.
This thing has like crazy...
You can't see, but it's like...
It's got a lot of...
Oh, who noticed?
Did they wake him up?
Okay, I'll go down.
Yeah, a lot of durability.
Bye!
Found you!
Wait, this is actually bad.
This is actually bad.
Shit.
This might be bad.
Okay, we got him.
We got him.
Another man down.
No!
Don't you dare!
That's my line.
Yeah, take him down.
He's healing them.
Yeah, he heals them.
That's crazy.
Oh, wait.
Are they back up then?
Oh no.
That's so messed up!
We got the medic at least.
Hopefully there's not another one.
Look at all these guys!
There's so many guys!
Take their butt.
Skella!
Your venue is great.
Music is amazing.
And you even knew about the aquarium instead of just the airport.
Wait, what do you mean?
You did your best, champ.
You're so condescending.
But thank you!
I'm glad you liked it.
Nice!
The big durability baby.
I think this land is ours now.
I've claimed it.
And these vicious one-liners.
I know.
He's so sassy.
I don't need to skip across.
I can...
I can, you know, just walk.
What you got here?
Some stuff.
So they have found this place.
They just...
haven't done anything with it yet.
Alright.
Nothing.
Can't go through there.
Phantom Knight, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Medieval.
I'm an archeologist.
Is he still up?
Yeah, he got me.
Dang.
It's ok.
I've been getting...
Wait, so I've been taking their bandages, but I haven't been like holding on to them?
That's so messed up.
What's the point?
Oh, I just...
So that he can't heal, but like, come on Indy!
Use your brain!
Oh,
this is not... Let's get this bust.
What's that?
I want that.
Place the bust.
And grab.
Why do we want this?
This is like the lamest looking thing ever.
How long have you been here?
He says it so like...
Grab the bandage.
Alright.
Exit the catacombs.
I'm trying!
I'm trying to get out of here.
Let me go grab... Ok, this is a little bit of backtracking, but I'm gonna go...
Grab a torch.
Dang it, I should have grabbed one earlier.
It's my fault.
Should have grabbed one earlier.
There's only one that I know of.
It's all the way down there.
Burn and bonk.
Just in case... Oh wait, is this one?
Yes, ok, perfect.
We're running, we're running... Wait.
What is it?
What is it telling me to burn?
Is it that?
No, something turned red.
Did you guys see that?
I was looking over here.
My little cursor turned red for something.
Mysterious.
Oh.
Nevermind.
I was like, I'm on the cusp of a great discovery!
It ain't easy being cheesy.
Like that.
Wow.
I like that.
Ok, just saved.
I like when it does that.
It's so cool.
There's a ladder.
No, just kidding.
That's a wall.
I'm sorry for being so dumb.
Ok.
Put my torch!
LT to climb the whip.
That's right.
Thank you for reminding me.
This way.
Indy, go up.
There's something very confusing about this game in that...
You press A...
You press basically like X to climb up.
Which is down.
You know, the bottom button.
And then if you want to drop down...
You press Y, the top button.
It confuses me.
I didn't mean to jump.
Oh, there.
Ok.
Nice.
Good job, Indy.
Wait, what's that?
Stop climbing!
Stop climbing.
And...
Swing!
Oh, I made it.
Oh my god, I made it.
I don't think I was supposed to go all the way up.
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Whatever.
Spooky.
This is a secret.
Light.
Nice music, I know.
Very fits the atmosphere.
I think this is a secret.
I think this is the way out.
Light.
We need something for...
There.
You.
Wait, if I move you...
I believe we'll be trapped.
So instead I should move you.
And bust.
Nice.
And...
Then we do this.
We're getting it.
We're so good at this game.
We're so good at puzzles.
I haven't even looked through here yet.
Oh, that's water.
Do I want to go through here though?
Oh my gosh, this is a hole.
Wait, this area is huge.
Oh my god.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go back.
The other area didn't look quite as big.
Bustin'.
I thought that was a person.
Spooky.
Scary.
Scary spooky.
Spooky.
Spooky spooky scary scary.
Does this game have maps?
It does.
We're about to go...
Through here, which has...
Which has...
Wait.
Through here.
It's just this thing.
It's just this damn relic.
Why do we want this?
I don't understand.
Indiana Jones, please explain it to me.
All that work for a little among us.
Okay.
Onwards.
But we get the points.
We get the adventurer points.
That's like the big deal.
I don't think there's anything over there.
Nothing in there.
This way.
But this stuff is lit up, so...
I'm scared that maybe perhaps...
Some guys are around.
Why the music?
Why is there music?
They don't see me.
I want to take my... Well, I'll just take theirs.
Wait, wait, wait.
Where did they go?
I guess up.
Good job, Minky.
Thanks.
Oh, so they came from in here.
They were like, no, nothing in here.
We don't care.
Climb up the hole.
Again.
Oh, we really are back here.
Wow.
I'm just a priest and I fell into the hole.
That's so embarrassing.
I like how when we are Indiana Jones we have more health, actually.
It doesn't say this is a... This is a restricted area.
I'm just saying.
When I spend my points, did I get the extra health on Indy and not...
Like, did it only count for Indy and not for...
Anything else?
That'd be wild if that's the case.
I'm just gonna sneak past the guards.
Oh.
There are some guys noticing me.
Maybe that way would've been easier.
Seems like there's two guys over here.
Minky.
I'm Minky!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Gosh, man.
Well, we took his bandage.
Hold on, let me heal.
And then I'm gonna take his bandage.
Can I please... Sometimes I press things and they don't work out the way that I want.
Anyway, now... Oh, no, no.
Wait, I wanted your bandage!
Oh, that's so messed up.
So now I used it for no reason.
Oh my god!
Oh, whatever.
Oh, no, I thought this one would open.
Where am I?
I know I'm supposed to go up the hole, but...
I can't help but think I'm lost.
It's a sneaking suspicion, guys.
Where the hell am I?
That's a really big circle, huh?
Wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, wait.
How did I... Wait.
What door...
This one.
The great circle.
Absolutely.
I'm keep knocking everybody out.
Or killing them.
There's not gonna be anybody left in this town.
When I'm through with it.
What is... Someone noticed me?
No.
I'm sneaking.
Yeah, we went in here, but there was nothing in here.
I don't think there's still anything in here.
Doesn't seem like it, at least at the moment.
We can at least... It's a good vantage point, I guess.
Guys, I don't remember how to use my gun.
I think that might be important to remember.
Just saying.
Oh, these guys.
Think he
sees me?
Did he just go...
Left on the D-pad.
Thank you!
They're getting better at guarding.
Oh my god.
Hold your horses!
It's the fact that they just like...
Whistle, whistle, whistle, whistle.
We don't notice a single thing.
I don't know where to put this guy.
I was gonna try and hide their bodies, but...
I think I can take these two.
My bandages.
That medic really screwed me over.
Is there another guy?
I know I don't have to take all the guys down, but...
Remember to eat.
Yeah, let's eat.
There's a lot of fruit around town.
I'll just save this one.
Alright, nice.
I think we took them all out.
I'll take your... whatever.
Did not take them all out.
Oh, I see him.
Yo, it just used up all the extra stamina that I saved up.
Gameplay style is actually pretty accurate, because movie Indy does get himself beat up quite a bit before winning fights too.
You know, you being bad is actually accurate.
Thanks for the confidence boost.
It is true though.
Indy, you know, he is a good...
Adventurer, but he does get his ass beat a lot a lot.
Sorry, I was really tired.
Sorry.
Okay, let's try and go up the hall.
Floating helmet?
No.
Looked like it was for a second.
How do I?
Go through here?
I suppose.
I guess through here?
Wait, no!
We went through here.
They are just chilling, staring at the wall.
I think they are having their own moment.
La la la la la la la la.
Oh my gosh, the sunlight.
La la la la la.
I think I can grab that.
I think I should also change.
Wrong thing.
Let's put on my suit.
Lovely.
Oh, I'm back here.
Oh, this is a restricted zone.
Hot lady.
What are you doing?
Argh!
I fell in there!
I'm such a silly clumsy priest.
He helped me!
Unlike all these other guys.
Madame.
G.E.D.
Oh?
Yeah, pretty.
Pretty lady.
Lockpicking nun.
Is everyone still in this area all down?
Or they just leave?
I don't see anyone.
Here we go.
She's probably right here and she's going to get us with a knife against our neck.
Apostolic Palace.
What do we have here?
Oh no!
The Japanese bombs killed hundreds in Shanghai.
Japanese air raid has shocked Nantou, a district in the city of Shanghai killing hundreds of Chinese civilians and wounding hundreds more.
No warning has been issued by the Japanese army which had previously promised to give for the civilian population to leave the area.
Around 3 million people live in Shanghai making it one of the largest cities in the world.
I think that's an understatement.
Indiana Jones.
Oh right!
We can unlock this now.
Good, good, good.
War never changes.
I can't tell, it's really decorative.
What's that?
Oh.
Take that.
Repair kit.
Is this a door?
No.
Pretend door.
Make you really confused.
I got the clerical key.
I hear someone talking.
I hear her.
Uh, anyone see a nun?
What do you mean by that, Andy?
He's so stupid sometimes.
Nice.
My dear fellow Wisp brethren, which version of our favorite ghost maid is the wiggliest?
Mint 1.0, 2.0, 2.0 in small form, 3.0 chibi or chibi...
Wait, what's 2.0 in small form?
Welcome to membership, thank you.
Whoa, oh god.
Oh my god,
I don't think there's something right in this city.
I think there's something really wrong here.
If I
get close to her, she's fine.
But, you know...
She might be a lizard person.
When I back up, she's like...
Oh my god!
Samuel, thank you for...
Well, I mean, membership, welcome to membership.
Because I thank you for the joining.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, a priestess card.
A tarot card depicting the high priestess major Arcana.
She knows too much.
I'm also praying.
Everybody else is fine, but this is the imposter.
Everybody...
I found the imposter.
Excuse me.
Ok, nevermind.
Oh, we found her.
I took so much time staring at other women.
Watching the Minky on the telly.
Thank you.
Rude.
Oh my gosh, it's parking.
Zeppelin.
Daaaa!
Mamma mia!
Welcome...
...to the top of this building.
It's pretty dangerous meeting up here.
It's Emerick Voss!
No!
Five mints?
Months?
Five mints!
Why do you have that?
Who?
Emerick Voss!
We've been six for eight months.
A cat!
A cat mommy.
Alex D, thank you for the three months!
What about this?
We ear anything that could be of interest to the other.
We trade information.
Deal?
Deal.
Yeah, alright.
Mr. Lombardi, deal.
Good.
You can call me Gina.
See you around, Strambo.
Strambo.
That's the spaghetti Rambo.
We should definitely bring this back to the library.
Yes.
Bring the parchment to Antonio.
Where the hell are we?
Wow!
Look at it up there!
It's so still.
I mean it has to be for people to disembark, but...
Wow, what a great view!
It's so cool.
Oh, I can take a picture.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Anchored airship.
Wait, hold on.
Can I leave from here?
I don't think I should.
But what?
I mean, maybe I can.
Actually, it's telling me to.
So...
Whoopsie-daisy!
Oh, dang it.
I did the thing again where I told you if I...
I hit up, but...
There's something not right in the city.
My god.
The city...
Oh, no.
This game...
No, no, no.
No, I did everything right!
I did everything correctly!
Oh, I think I'm supposed to take this.
Fruit bag.
Carry twice the amount of fruit.
Love that.
Anyway...
What's in here, anyway?
I can't take them.
I have very low health.
But I'm gonna take that.
Okay.
Important stuff down there?
Really?
But my low health...
What if I...
What the?
That's not a gun.
Excuse me?
Where did my gun go?
What is this?
Why do I have a staff?
Why do I have like a Goku staff?
What is this?
Oh, change outfit.
Okay,
is this the aim?
This is the aim.
Oh, reload.
That's RT.
Why don't you come up here?
I will go down once you're done, baby.
Oh, dammit.
Stop dancing.
Cut it out.
Indy?
That's kinda messed up.
Anyway.
I'm a man of the cloth.
Cool.
So we did that.
Okay.
And down.
Oh my gosh, I did it again.
No!
Okay.
Down.
Try with B?
Thanks, guys.
Wowee!
Oh, picture.
Oh yeah, they did have this thing right here.
Strange inscription.
Eighth inscription.
Yes!
Thank you guys!
Enter the boxing ring!
No way.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Take all my Google Rewards money.
I also use the Google Rewards.
Except I use it in Gacha.
Aww, thanks.
Those take like so long to collect.
Take that donut.
Take the medicine bottle.
Any other...
There's gotta be more medicine in there.
Wait, so now...
Oh my gosh.
I can go anywhere I please!
Was there anywhere else that needed a photo?
I kept getting like a little thing.
Oh, washing tent.
Really?
Indy, you freak.
Now I have all access.
Thank you guys for making me come down here.
Go up, Indy.
Oh gosh.
You can make it.
Nice.
I missed some money?
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine.
Alright, we are going back to the...
I know exactly where we are.
Just don't get spotted by the captains.
Got it.
Hello!
Is this a captain?
Ciao!
Fast travel is over here.
I think.
Bless you.
Yeah, right here.
We are trying to go to the courtyard?
The courtyard.
Very nice.
Good job, Indy.
Will they let us inside the...
Ciao!
Hey!
Will they let us inside here?
Mmm.
Nice.
She'll never recover.
Okay, good.
Requires clerical suit.
Well, since I'm not being perceived...
I think I'm just going to go right over here.
And change.
Nice.
Nicholas!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Damn right, Indy.
I bet I did, yeah.
Take it.
You want to see it?
Take it!
I'm going to have a bit of a snack.
Amity got me some cheese bites.
Investigate the fountain.
Wow, these are really crunchy.
Sorry.
Hold on.
My YouTube chat broke again.
I'm so sorry you guys.
I have to refresh.
Augur.
Cheese bite ASMR.
Yeah!
I got to meet up with Amity.
I got to meet up with Amity and Sunny and Mogu!
And Mogu.
She's so sweet.
She made a little...
Like a little...
Wisp keychain that she made herself.
You know when you use the pins on the felt?
So I got to say hi to everybody.
Okay, now I change again.
We're going to the fountain.
To the fountain, to the fountain, to the fountain...
This way.
Wait.
Where is the fountain?
This way.
Any loose ends?
A nun in trouble?
What do you mean a nun in here?
Hello.
Thank you.
Oh no, no, no.
It might be a bad idea.
We're fine.
We're okay.
We're fine, probably.
Hi.
I saw a camera thing.
Camera for where?
Where?
Ornate door.
Okay.
Now time to steal some stuff.
I used to be handsome too.
Hello.
They're watching me like a hawk, man.
I'm going to take a look.
Take.
Okay.
Hey, buddy.
Steal a hundred.
A hundred euros.
Euros!
I got to put this guy to sleep for good.
Oh, nothing?
Stop staring at me.
Turn around.
I want to go to the other place.
Over here.
I thought there was a nun in here that was in trouble.
What's this?
Open it up.
Shipment report.
Lock shipment wall open.
Contents are confidential.
Urgent.
Signature.
Hector de Luca.
Counter signature.
M.
Barone.
Additional notes.
Geo.
Most likely, Centurione de Luca decoded the key for the wrong day.
It's a Lyra sign.
What's a Lyra sign?
What's that?
Check your journal for side quests.
True.
Easy fix, but you should make him wait his turn or next we'll be tying his shoes for him too.
Confidential.
Brawler?
I'll take that.
Absolutely.
What are we learning?
Brawler, brawler, brawler, brawler.
Deal increased damage in armed and hand-to-hand melee combat.
Nice.
Where do I see... let's see.
Fieldwork at the Mad Priest.
A nun in trouble.
The secret of giants.
A savage discovery.
What's a Mad Priest?
There's a Sister Catherine in Sistine Chapel waiting for a delivery boy from Antonio.
It concerns Father Kijinju, the Bad Priest who made the map of secret inscriptions.
So I need...
Find Sister Catherine.
Let's track that one.
Talk to Gina, track... oh.
I can only track one at a time.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh.
So close.
Tales of dread.
Be amazed by this horrible tale of darkness, death and descent into madness.
Thank you.
Good thing nobody saw me steal it.
Yeah.
Did Moku stink like we all suspected?
What do you mean stink?
She smells lovely.
Indeed.
He has such a fast hand, you know.
I wanted to go back in there.
I guess I didn't need anything.
I think there was one more thing I wanted in there.
Nothing in here maybe.
Oh wait.
Do any of these open?
Bandage.
Definitely need that.
I think there was a bandage in the other room too.
And I wanna go get it.
I'm gonna go around the back way.
There's a...
Hey.
There's a lock to open in that tent.
In which one?
Hey.
It was a revolver.
That's what it was.
I don't see... wait.
What did I...
Something popped up?
Maybe not.
Oh no, the shipment report.
That's it.
No!
Mamma mia.
I could eat a cow.
He said the thing.
He said it.
Mamma mia.
He said the thing.
Let me check in here one more time if there's a locker that I missed.
A lock to pick?
Doesn't show me anything.
I guess we're fine.
Oh, I could have snuck in here at any time.
That's a little scary.
Can you... Oh my gosh.
Who?
Who's... How?
Who's sneak is so... so vast?
What?
How would you...
Oh my god.
Eat.
Okay.
Doesn't the guy come in here?
And like start walking around.
We're good for now.
I'm one of the guys.
I should be able to take any fruit that I want, right?
It's not just their fruit.
It could be my fruit.
I don't know.
Who's looking at me?
Uh oh.
Huh?
Oh.
It's my... It's my money too.
And I'm sick of acting like it's not my money also.
Who's money... Who's just leaving their money around then?
It's my money too.
I want to take the medicine bottle.
Alright.
So we're following...
This.
What?
Wait, huh?
Oh.
I'm going up?
Okay.
Nobody noticed me.
Here we go.
Yeah.
I don't see their name on it either.
Exactly.
Hello.
Inside.
Up.
Upsy-daisy.
Okay.
Now we make it this time.
We gotta... We gotta make the jump this time.
Oh my god.
Indy, don't scare me like that.
Please.
Nice.
This way.
What?
Why am I going this way?
Here?
Over here.
Okay.
Indy, shut up.
Why are you so loud?
I'm gonna keep it open maybe.
Which way?
It's like right in there.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
Perfect.
Hello!
Excuse me.
Clerical key.
Do I need to be a priest to go in there?
Quick change!
Wow!
Okay.
Nice.
Where is that delivery boy?
Hello.
I'm gonna eat more cheese bites.
I'm a delivery man.
But I'm gonna mute.
Okay.
Why is she looking up?
I get it now.
I was like, ma'am?
I'm right here.
Oh, I can take a picture of her.
Sister Catherine.
Did you say that to me?
What?
Who said that?
Oh, you!
Oh my God, you scared me.
Oh my God!
Cat mummy.
Hmm.
Did she just roll her eyes at me?
Ma'am?
She's going ghost.
Gina!
Gina is a figment of my imagination.
Gina, I won't let you leave.
Gina, I won't let you leave me, girl.
Gina!
There she goes.
Oh!
I'm such a gentleman.
Yes.
I love America.
This isn't...
All right, let's get this over with.
Oh no, she's crying.
What?
Jesus Christ, what have you done?
It's occupied.
That was the most indie thing ever.
No way!
Mother-in-law's letter.
My dear Vittorio, my heart is full of mixed emotions.
There is a matter of great importance I must share with you and Inez.
I am with child.
I know this is unexpected.
But in my eyes, it is a blessing that fills me with immense happiness.
It is true that the circumstances surrounding this are complicated, unconventional, and will surely raise many eyebrows.
But I believe we must face this together with open hearts and minds.
Love, Adriana.
This guy is in trouble, all right.
Follow Gina to the museum.
But also...
We have to get the mad priest.
Which is... go to get that kid.
Wow, that was messy.
Oh my God, four question marks!
Four question marks!
A little off topic, wanna say you're a legendary menace for suggesting last cup of coffee?
I wouldn't say menace.
You got Doki's back and we got your back, boss.
Thank you.
I wouldn't say menace.
Good type of menace.
Oh,
nice one.
The flying machine.
I love the... I love the way people look at me in this game.
They look so upset.
The menace was singing that and then giving two weeks notice.
This is Antonio, right?
Oh, wait, Antonio is our friend.
Hello.
Okay.
That's Sydney, you're right.
Who is this guy?
Also, look!
My photos!
Why... I thought I got way more.
Awkward.
I thought I took way more photos of these things than just four of them.
Why aren't they hung up?
Hello.
Antonio.
You're my Italian streamer now.
Oh, I guess I didn't give them to him, maybe.
What?
What if the giant we saw was a baby giant?
What if there is actually a huge giant?
Oh, okay, good.
We have to go over there.
Wait, that's the key, the sewer key that we needed earlier.
Nice.
That's an oxymoron.
How is that an oxymoron?
Giants have to be babies at some point too.
Right?
Ventura's letter.
Wait, did he just teleport?
For
those who don't know...
Game glitches are some of my favorite things ever, ever, ever to watch in the world.
Like, I love watching compilations of Red Dead Redemption glitches.
Just any type of game, especially ones that are like AAA titles that just have like...
Game glitches that are just so ridiculous.
They're so funny.
I love them.
So when stuff like that happens, I know some people get upset about it.
They're like, my version.
Skyrim has the best glitch IMO?
What else?
I don't know if I've ever watched Skyrim once.
It's always AAA games too.
I know!
I know some people get upset because you pay so much money for it to be glitchy and silly.
But I just eat it up.
I'm like...
Gosh, I love it!
It's so great!
Antonio, these black shirts are operating under my authority.
And you will not hinder them in gathering suspected contraband books for inspection.
If you threaten to beat them about the head with a crucifix again, you will have me to answer to.
May the Lord have mercy on your soul.
Father Cesar Ventura.
You see that on the phone?
This guy is heavy breathing.
Hey, I have more photos to give you.
Oh, you want me to do it myself?
I've taken way more than just four!
This is ridiculous!
I've taken way more than just four of them.
I'm so confused.
Are they in the bag?
I don't think so.
No, they're not.
You can check your journal.
Hmm...
I don't know.
So I have to find all the rest of them for them to go on the board at once?
Is that how it works?
Go to Secret of the Giants.
See, I've gotten 8 out of 10!
I've gotten 8 out of 10 of them.
So I'm close.
I was like, there's no way that I've only found 4.
That's ridiculous.
You have to give them the rest to fill the board.
Ah, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I thought he meant like, put them up yourself.
Okay, okay.
So we'll do that.
But...
We also have this.
Get to the... I don't want to go to the sewers.
I thought I was going here.
Hold on.
Let's follow Gina first.
I don't know.
If I miss some...
I want to say also, if I miss some of these other missions...
I'm not intending on...
100%ing anything or the game or anything like that, so...
If I miss some, that's okay.
Whoa, what happened to the quality all of a sudden?
Wow, you can even see it up from here!
Wow, that's cool.
This game takes quite a bit to 100%.
Yeah.
I imagine.
I figured it would be like that.
Looks like it's syncing.
Why did the quality get so bad all of a sudden?
I think the quality...
from when I played on PC...
also transferred over to the Xbox.
So, honestly, I just didn't change them.
So, it probably could look much better.
And I'm, you know...
denying us all that.
Hello?
Why are you climbing up on top of a bucket?
Indy!
Here.
I can never remember the pathway.
Some light bugs on the Xbox version.
Ah, it is there.
I don't...
Let's do Gina's thing first.
Okay, I'm trying not to get seen and I'm gonna change.
Nice.
Okay.
Um, excuse me?
Sir?
Wait.
Actually, this works.
This is fine.
This is fine, everybody.
They knew...
people would do this.
Sean, thanks for 8 months.
Thank you!
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Oh, I thought they covered it.
I was gonna be like, no way!
It's in here, right?
Yeah.
Hello.
Excuse me.
I can't believe it.
Wow.
They love that statue so much, they made the same guy twice.
You ever just think about how bored people were back in like...
You know, the ancient days.
Where they're like, I'm gonna make the most detailed statue ever.
It's how I look, IRL.
I believe you.
Like, to make the same statue identical.
What the?
Oh my god.
No access, huh?
Well, I'm...
I always forget what...
No, no, no!
Please!
There we go.
Thank you.
They 3D printed it?
It's... yeah, probably.
Probably.
But I can go in.
Can't even trust nuns these days?
Why do you think so many of the old statues are naked?
They're just bored.
They're like, man, I...
Would really love to look at...
Something sexy right now.
I don't know.
I don't know who perceived me, but someone did.
I'm looking around a little bit.
I wanna loot if I can.
Up there.
Okay.
Oh, there's a little tent.
I shall go in.
Wait.
You're not the guy I need to worry about.
Ciao!
Mystery note.
Oh, the secret delivery letter.
Okay, there's a lot.
Shipment from first zone.
Your eyes only.
Code key dice.
Someone has written a note at the bottom.
The code must be wrong.
Shipment arrived on Wednesday.
Should be 4718.
No luck.
Get engineer to look into it.
4718.
There's a note on October 20th.
Code look up table.
Confidential.
Memorize and destroy.
The numbers... Oh, someone didn't do that.
The numbers for the letters C, D, E and I are circled in the column for Wednesday.
We'll just take that, dude.
Oh my god!
Are you asleep?
Oh, he's asleep.
I always get my camera out first on accident.
I think that's the guy that didn't do his job.
I thank you, sir.
And I will thank you... Oh, that looks important.
I'll thank you by not waking you up.
It was
4718, right?
4718.
He said it should be 4718.
Hold on.
Oh, and we got some bread.
Do this every time.
Chomp, chomp, chomp.
Biscotti.
Let me check my notes.
How do I... Where do I find it, anyway?
It said it was everything but that.
No!
Field notes?
Field notes... Oh, thank you.
Oh, goodness.
Fungi recipe!
Where the hell is it?
Hold on.
Hold.
Hold!
No.
Brown cat.
Black and white cat.
Guys,
I can't find it.
Oh, it's mysteries.
Thank you.
Wednesday.
Okay.
So, dice.
D...
So, dice...
And it'd be Wednesday.
Okay, hold on.
Wednesday is mare.
The ones that are circled.
D...
D... 4...
I... 7...
4...
Okay, Indy, please.
Hold on.
4...
See?
Yeah, dice is circled.
4...
I...
4... 7...
Oh, wait.
That's the same thing that we tried.
I'm stupid.
I'm silly.
Okay, hold on.
Shipment arrived on Wednesday.
And that's when... that's...
What we have written.
Should be 4718.
No luck.
Get an engineer...
You're just dealing with the same problem they had.
Right?
This is the shipment container, right?
I only have 3 out of 4 notes though.
I'm missing one.
Oh, the fourth note is in the chest.
Let's see.
October 15th.
But...
Then...
Would be...
6...
3...
6... 3...
8... 0...
Right?
Oh my god!
Only 10 euros!
Mystery note.
Wait, hold on.
Let's grab the medicine.
Medicine bottles?
That's huge!
It's a map guide.
I thought I said apologies.
Mario!
Is that Duce?
The people loved it.
Glad you had fun Raccoon!
Fertility?
Does not drink of course.
Who I'm sure would find this a fitting souvenir of his visit to Italy.
Do not forget to ensure that the gift is presented on my behalf.
A favor is repaid with a favor, son.
I enclosed some leisure money for you in the crate.
Spend it wisely.
Completed!
Medicine!
We did it!
One thing I wanted to do too was...
We got fruit bag.
It's kind of expensive.
We also got Vatican medicine.
You don't even need...
You can just inspect...
Nevermind.
You can't just use it.
Just kidding.
What is splinter smash again?
The last hit before an improvised weapon break deals additional damage.
It's in my journal.
Gosh, this stuff says so much.
There it is.
I drove 13 hours to attend the concert!
It was absolutely worth it.
You did a phenomenal job.
Can't wait to see you perform again in the future.
Thanks, Telegram!
Didn't you give me a letter?
I got it.
Thank you!
13 hours though.
Maybe I did.
Maybe I received it.
Thank you!
Cool.
Investigate the fountain.
Wait, look at that!
Oh no, we shouldn't...
They said to take care of everything in the Vatican...
Before we investigate this fountain.
But we know where the fountain is.
Which is good.
I'm coming.
Hello.
Hello?
Ma'am, please.
Ma'am?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
Ma'am?
I don't think the staff... I don't think it's over there.
What is she doing?
I don't think it's over there.
Drops the large evil anvil on the ghost's head.
Why?
Locked.
Oh my God, I took that one too.
Excuse me.
I guess we... I know this is a restricted area, but are we safe?
Why is she running like this?
Ma'am?
Don't just stand there!
Oh no!
No!
No one heard that though, right?
She was... She was so awesome.
Ok.
I should take his outfit, you know?
Oh wow.
Where?
Oh, no?
This?
Roman murals.
Duh.
Roman, duh.
We're supposed to do it together.
It's... Why is she leaping?
Oh my God, you gotta keep...
You didn't even make it!
Why did she stand in corners?
Gina.
Gina, my girl, Gina.
Come on.
Gina, come on!
Oh there she is.
Ok.
And he fights like one too.
What were you doing?
Come on.
No!
Oh well.
Come in.
Like a wet noodle.
Oh!
The goat.
A lot of boobs.
I was born in the wrong era.
Gina, I can hide under here.
I was looking at the animal.
What are you looking at?
Oh, that doesn't look very good.
Handprint.
I don't think a handprint is not the first thing I thought of.
From a black shirt's uniform.
Ok.
Was this a note?
Gina's note?
What kind of hat?
That's what I'm wondering.
Giuliana, I want you to investigate something.
There's a strange American professor here looking for his lost cat mummy.
He tells me that he is from Marshall College in Connecticut.
Maybe you can check with your contact in the Vatican Secret Agency.
Gina.
I wonder what made her drop it.
Giuliana.
Ma'am.
Oh.
Ok.
Ok, ok, ok.
Oh, I found it.
Giuliana Franco.
Wait.
Oh, wow.
I'm doxing her?
I'm so sorry.
We literally know everything about her now.
We know her mom.
Damn.
I wish I could see anything.
Why don't you find anything?
What?
Oh she did...wow.
I asked and she found...
Huh?
Taken during infiltration of Costello.
What?
Wow.
Ok, now we can go.
Lockpick.
Someone...
How did I not notice that?
That's kind of freaky.
What do you mean ex-Gina?
What does that mean?
Footprints.
Oh, sorry.
I'm a little clumsy.
Please forgive me, Gina.
Press X to Gina.
Ok.
There's another scuffle here.
And those footprints look like...none prints.
None your business.
Sorry, I didn't...I tried to...
Let's keep going.
Huh?
Blood.
And there's something shiny here.
Glitters?
Oh!
The murdering nun.
There's three of them.
What do you want me to...
Lady?
What the hell?
That lady keeps running off.
Yeah, it left me.
This bitch.
Let's see if there's anything else in here.
Your friend is in a tower.
We know where she is now.
Oh, I missed.
What's this?
I need to find a nun.
Are you talking?
The plumber.
Wait.
Wait, but this...
You guys!
What could it be?
It's really bright in here.
We went all the way out here.
There you go.
Oh!
I got...
A drinking horn.
A golden drinking horn from the 9th century A.D.
found in a Swedish Viking King burial mound near Uppsala.
It belongs in a museum.
Hello.
Okay.
What am I doing now?
Let's go back to the mad priest.
Oh, the sewers.
I don't want to go to the sewers.
Oh, we have so much more stuff that's been...
Okay, Savage Discovery, we finished.
Secret of the Giants.
Kitty.
Secret of the Giants, we're so close to completing.
Let's just do that.
This game is huge.
I know, right?
My goodness.
This is open.
This way.
This way?
You're walking away from a picture.
The one on the wall?
I already got that one.
One of the photos is near.
Like the one right over here?
That one right there?
I don't understand...
He's feeding the pigeon.
Steppy, step on the pigeon.
What's the other photo I can take here?
Sorry, my hand slipped.
This?
Bird feeding?
It really is this.
Thank you sir.
There is nothing else over here?
I'm so confused.
How am I supposed to find these?
Good morning, Mito.
Good morning, Mito!
I'll just run.
In there?
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Heavy breathing, Indy.
Just walking with my book.
Don't mind me.
Walking with my book.
Literally making circles.
Huh?
There's one on the fountain, I guess?
Maybe?
Bless you.
Isn't this the guy we need to watch out for?
He might be.
God, please sir.
What the?
That's not...
What?
There's...
Up, up, up?
Hole?
Up here?
Oh my goodness.
Ninth!
And then the last.
The last.
The last?
Or like, good luck buddy.
No help.
You need to do the mad priest.
Alright,
we are going to the sewers.
Sewers, sewers, baby.
Okay, so...
Sewers were...
I think I remember.
I'm just going to follow, honestly, the...
Yeah.
Buona giornata.
This way.
But we are getting stuff done, I guess.
In terms of quests and all.
How long have I been playing this for?
Sorry!
You okay computer?
My goodness.
Four hours, oh my gosh.
She's a ghost.
She's a phantom.
Freaky phantom.
She's a phantom, phantom.
Everybody is sneezing here.
Everybody is going to die.
No, that's not the guy we need to be worried about.
That's the guy we need to be worried about.
Excuse me.
Going into the sewers.
Down here.
No room for donuts.
I kind of want a donut now.
Is that that guy?
Oops.
How is there a trash can down here?
It's so awful.
My bad.
Do I...
Dive in?
Down there?
I can't see anything.
Wait.
Nasty.
The jump for like...
I see now.
The jump like from land...
Swimming to land is like really crazy.
Gamers don't look at...
What am I doing over here though?
Is this the palace entrance you desire?
Up here?
Streamers don't look up.
Streamers or gamers?
How do I reach it?
Up here?
Come on.
Come on Indy.
No?
Oh my god.
Please, Indy.
Call windows?
What do you mean windows?
White paint.
It's a white paint moment.
The white part?
What white part?
This one right here?
Oh!
And here?
And go up?
I'm gonna fall.
Pull up the pipe?
I'm trying!
Why are you crouched, Indy?
Wait.
No, I keep going on the table.
That, maybe that one right there.
I keep going over, over, over.
And over to this one maybe.
Oh gosh, Indy.
Indy, your stamina.
Barbie!
Data
Jones!
Oh my god!
Yeah, I'm very disappointed in Indy right now.
He's an older gentleman now.
Not in this game!
Don't give me that!
If you stop it replenishes your...it does?
Oh, you're right.
Perfect.
Barbie!
Good job, Indy.
And over.
His little grunts.
His little groans.
Nice.
Go up!
Why didn't he go up?
The great circle continues.
OK, spider monkey.
I was stuck in here for like 20 minutes.
My gosh, just what the hell?
I'm so confused.
What did I do wrong?
Gentle drop.
Indy.
What do you mean land on the pipes?
It says to climb the whip.
It literally gives me the tutorial.
I did it.
I had to.
I had to change my camera angle.
Are you for real?
Be for real right now.
No way.
I had to change my camera angle.
Oh my god.
OK, wait.
Am I going all the way up there?
Yep.
Oh, OK.
Don't hit that.
You lose all momentum.
Momentum.
Oh my gosh and we did it.
We got the final one.
Nice.
Oh, there we go.
Yippee!
Tenth inscription.
OK, find the palace entrance.
Oh, that's...this way.
Oh my gosh.
We did it guys.
Good job us.
Where is this anyway?
If I put on a black shirt uniform...
Am I going to be OK?
I don't remember why I'm in here.
Oh, we're finding out secrets of the giants.
This is not a door.
This is a door.
OK,
never mind.
Even being in an outfit makes you not safe.
So in this outfit it is, baby.
Nice.
How many guys do you think are in here?
I saw one.
Me, me.
Iron grip.
Take that.
Where did that guy go?
Oh, he's walking outside.
He's coughing.
What's this?
Document.
Pompeian death mask.
Oh, confiscation manifest.
Oh, obscene idol.
Is that me?
Jointed death figurine.
No, that's me.
Demonic kidney form seal.
Acceptable.
That spooked me.
Is there a guy?
Oh no, that's not a guy.
I wish I had a weapon.
Can I unlock this?
Nice.
I don't know where this leads out to either, but we have another exit, which is always good.
Photo.
Vatican seal.
Here?
Nice.
Alright, put that away.
My fists are my weapons.
Oh, we're at the dig site.
I don't think I need to...
Stolen artifacts.
Picture proof.
Nice.
I don't think I need to get him then.
Right?
Because...
There's probably somebody in here I need to get.
Oh wait, just kidding.
I do need to go that way.
I'm an idiot.
Wait, there's something over there.
Oh I have to find the diary.
Yeah, duh.
We're finding the diary everybody.
Oh, maybe in here?
Bingo.
Grab it.
Got it.
I'm so good.
I'm so stealthy.
Girl smell, girl smell, girl smell.
Indy, I don't... this is not the place.
Indy, this is not the place.
Yeah, I went there.
Yeah.
That's what that other guy said.
That the giants come out at night.
Or rather in the darkness.
Spooky.
Ok, so now we return to her.
Where is this?
Oh.
What the hell?
You were asleep!
God dammit.
Oh, that's where I was going to put you actually.
I wanted your fruit, so I was just going to...
Ok, well this works too I guess.
Get that lemon, get that orange, get that other lemon.
Oh, you got some bread here too.
Don't mind if I do.
Yeah, thank you.
And I'm going to change back into our little friend's outfit.
Perfect.
Cat?
Where?
Kitty.
Where the hell am I?
Cat!
You are just so cute!
Oh wow.
No, I wanted you stretching.
I wanted you stretching.
Oh, your fur.
It's a little scraggly.
That's ok.
No!
One star?
Cats are five star items.
Perfect!
Why are you like this?
Indiana Jones.
Say prunes.
Where am I?
Wait, did I need to go back up?
No, I'm going my own way.
Oh, I know where I am.
I know where I am.
And then I'm back here.
Yeah.
I knew.
Andy is a dog person.
He is.
Let's see.
Give the diary to sister Catherine.
Important.
Hey, I'm busy.
Don't talk to me.
Alright.
Even if you are a dog person or a cat person, it doesn't mean you should be mean.
You know, depending.
You should not be mean to the other.
You guys, we can go into the box.
We can go in here.
Oh my god, we got welcomed in by Solidus.
You don't know who I am.
How do you know who I am?
No,
that's...
Oh.
Hi.
What did I get myself into?
Oh, really?
He's in his undies.
Oh.
What?
It's so expensive.
Oh my god.
What is this one?
Hard boiled.
Hardened protection by merging two health bars into one.
Pretend he's a medic.
What?
Oh.
Thanks.
First time I've ever gotten money legally.
Well, I guess this isn't really legal, but you know.
Oh.
Yeah, I took your ass out, dummy.
What is this?
Can I take this?
Or...
First guy has no pants.
Second guy has no shirt.
Look at him.
He's huge though.
He's huge!
Wait, did I take my money?
Don't drag me out!
I can keep going!
Did I take my money?
No!
Bad angle.
What do you mean?
There.
Got a parry.
Bandages on post.
Oh, thank you!
Wait, are these like unlimited bandages?
That'd be sick.
Why always bad apple?
Because it sounds like bad angle.
Yeah, but unlimited?
No way.
Awesome!
Hold on, I'm going to eat some bread.
Boo!
I need more bread.
Yeah.
Alright.
Hey!
Oh, I can dodge?
Oh my God.
Why is this so much more difficult?
Press to review hand to hand combat controls.
Oh my God!
He hits so hard!
Oh,
I didn't...Wait, no, I was on...I was on health.
Why didn't it give me a lemon?
He has the dominant genes.
I hope they replenish the donuts.
I'm always going to come here for...
They didn't!
No!
I'll take a fig.
Nice.
Wait, oh, there's some stuff over here.
What's this?
And then lemons.
I think though guys, maybe we'll try next time with him.
How much money do I have anyway?
I have enough money!
I do have enough money for these.
And this one is...
Bandage inventory capacity is increased by one.
Thank you!
Iron grip.
No, not yet.
Hard boiled.
Nice!
Egg powers.
Yeah.
Indie can clinch enemies for longer.
Ah, look at that!
I've never done that before though.
We'll do that next time.
I don't quite feel like doing it anymore.
Not a fighter, eh?
Shut up.
I'm busy.
I'm busy!
We gotta go deliver this to sister Catherine.
And then we go to Antonio.
And then maybe next time we do the fountain.
Since I'm starting to get hungry.
Walking around with the dog.
But I think we made good progress today.
Change!
The door just immediately opened.
Where is the delivery?
I'm right here!
Hey sister.
Thanks.
Why?
You think I'm the...
From Boston.
I mean she speaks perfect English so...
What?
Yeah.
Father Gallagher.
He looks like the guy from Hunchback of Notre Dame.
Hellfire!
Yeah, that guy.
Snooping.
Whoa, what a great shot.
Yay!
Making progress.
That's what I said.
Nice.
So now...
We can do Secret of the Giants.
That's just going back to...
Oh wait, I want to do a Nun in Trouble too.
Borgia Tower.
OK.
I want to finish the side quest before we go back to the main one, you know?
So...
We'll do these two.
And then we can kick off the next stream with the fountain.
With the continuing cat mummy.
Rafi!
Thanks for the gift!
Quick travel.
Go to Antonio.
Antonio.
Bless you.
Everybody sneezes here.
I think they are all infected.
There is something seriously wrong going on in here.
And it's not just the obvious stuff.
There are other underlying horrible things going on here.
Isaac!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you, thank you!
Tiny Tiefling!
Thank you for the five gift!
Thank you so much!
I'm back!
Oh my
God!
I can't hear it!
I can't hear!
Princess Denmark, thank you for the ten gift!
What just...
Oh my fucking God!
Are you kidding me?
No!
All that for this thing!
You have to be kidding me!
OK.
The tower.
I don't even know what we...
It's a tool for later?
Is it really?
Because I have no idea what we use it for.
I just keep collecting them.
I have no idea.
A picture of him?
That's so sweet.
OK.
All the way up there.
Gosh, I love this view!
Eventually you make a circle out of them.
No!
What?
Is that the great circle?
Don't, don't, don't, don't get my hopes up.
Don't get my hopes up.
Ah!
Oh.
My bad.
Stop staring!
I'm trying to change!
Gross.
Indiana Jones is the prologue to Among Us all along.
Ending will probably be Indy playing Among Us with his friends using the relics.
This relic is sus.
Hello?
Indy.
What is wrong with you?
What the?
Oh my god.
I've never done that before.
Oh, it's here.
The white bit.
Coughing baby.
Oh, excuse me.
Please, Indy.
Why do you do this?
Why do you do this to me?
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
The climbing sometimes in this game is so whack.
Please, stand up.
Ok.
Why are we crouched?
In here.
Yeah, you left me for dead.
You left me for dead.
Follow me.
Actually, don't.
Because I don't... Why would you say that?
I don't know where I'm going.
I mean, of course there are, but...
She's ready for combat.
Get him.
Sick him.
Sick him, girl.
Oh my gosh.
There's several people.
Ok, maybe we can get this guy first.
Oh, this guy first.
Nevermind.
Oh my gosh, what are you doing?
Ma'am, do something!
Yeah!
Oh, ouch!
Where's your weapon?
Hey!
Leave her alone!
Oh my god.
Take the donut.
Oh, is that?
Oh no, that's a bottle.
Nevermind.
Ma'am, you did this!
I was hiding and then you ruined it!
Anyway...
God damn!
Almost blew our...
Oh, top of the tower.
No!
We're back!
She's working for the enemy.
I swear to god.
She just ran in front of him.
Minto, I watched yours and Doki's concert online.
The both of you and the guests all have wonderful stage presence and knocked it out of the park.
Can't stop singing along with you all.
Thank you, Tri Princess!
I appreciate it so much!
Oh, the tower card.
That's kind of... That's fitting, right?
Thanks, Indy.
Get some original thoughts, my man.
Oh, thank you!
I think somebody almost slipped the wrong way with his neck.
He broke his neck.
He's that committed to the cause, you know?
He'll break his neck for this.
Oh yeah, baby!
That's for the next book.
It sounds like the Looney Tunes theme.
Oh,
I think that's the guy outside.
The whistling man.
How do I...
Um...
That's Tom and Jerry's theme?
Oh...
Whatever.
Anyway...
Requires Juliana's key?
Bitch, get over here!
Oh, maybe I go over here.
Crap.
Oh!
Juliana is her friend.
Sorry, she keeps bringing her up, so I got the names confused.
Left?
There is a space?
There is?
Here?
Oops.
There?
Go up?
What do you mean?
Where up?
The white sheet?
This thing?
It blended in, you guys.
I thought it was...
It blended in.
I really thought it was its own thing.
Oh my god, we got a Pepe recipe.
400 grams spaghetti.
Peppercorns.
Pecorino.
Nice.
Where did my weapon go?
Okay, I still have it.
I think.
I sure hope.
Pepe.
This area is kind of spooky.
Is there anyone around here?
Maybe not.
Okay, I dropped down.
Alright, but what else is up here?
We got some bread.
I'm always... No, I didn't want to eat that!
I'm always eating bread.
I'm too fast at this game.
Can I get a...
Get a blessing for...
The fancy walnut and choco chip cookies that I got out of the oven.
That sounds amazing!
Thank you!
Please share.
Thank you.
Blessing!
Be delicious!
Moe!
I might have to possess you later though.
Sorry.
Can I tear this apart?
No.
I have to block.
Okay.
Easy.
Sounds like she was running away from something.
What are you doing?
Ma'am, what are you doing?
Come on.
Gina is kind of silly you guys.
I'm starting to realize.
She was going to come up you guys.
She was going to come up here.
We got him.
Easy.
Steal their stuff.
Take their things.
Take their meds.
Take your meds!
More money!
Nice.
You can never not have enough money, right?
Did she already go up?
She is so fast.
Girl, hold on!
There is double weight.
That's so fun.
Or is that her?
There she is.
Oh my god.
I thought I was seeing things for a second.
Wow, this is a nice room.
Anything?
Oh, meds in here.
Pills here.
Grab this just in case.
Lockpick!
Lockpick.
To the Jones.
What about my weapon?
I think I got him.
Take your time.
Interrogation document.
He is just a cream puff.
Suspect Anon was found near Officer Rodolfo's body.
Claims to have found him already dead.
Suspect refuses to talk.
Clearly has previous interrogation experience.
Perhaps a communist spy?
She will break eventually and reveal her co-conspirators.
Need to inform Father Ventura that communist spies may have infiltrated the Vatican.
Take your time.
Oh, I'll help.
I guess.
It's so cute when he put it like that.
As all good men do.
Aww,
missing cat.
We are key.
We took care of everybody.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I know.
I did that.
That's how they took the picture of me.
Yeah, I already know.
Thank you.
Yeah, they spoiled which door it is.
Okay.
Wait, is that another?
Is that another side quest?
What?
Why did he look at the camera and say that?
I don't know what you mean actually, Indy.
I actually really...
No, new mystery!
I don't know what he means by that at all.
Oh, look at that!
Wait, all the fieldwork is done.
Wasn't there one more?
Or am I crazy?
Find the locked door.
I'm an acrobat.
Oh, Indy.
You're so silly.
It's that one over there.
Yup.
I don't think I was going to make that one, but yeah, cool.
Why is that thing still there?
You think it would run out of fuel?
What does that thing run on?
Medicine bottles.
Take that.
That's of it's own value.
Okay.
Why does she have the key for this?
Search the agent's room.
Who's a good boy?
I can't take a picture of you guys?
Oh my goodness!
Who's a good boy?
And a book.
Why does it have to be snakes?
Throttle.
Knock out unaware lightweight and medium weight enemies with a whip pull.
That sounds awesome.
Polybius Square Diagram.
Polybius Square used to construct and decode secret messages.
Mortis.
Are you okay?
The dog is really whimpering.
I'm worried for him.
Ah, here we go.
Italian poem.
I speak for God and not myself.
Some of the letters have been highlighted.
The dim and wasteful that was pure and bright.
He observes us all.
I'll look to him.
To sin is human.
To watch divine.
Some of the letters have been highlighted.
Okay.
I-R-I-A-T-A-S-A
The last one is an O?
Are you sure?
Two out of six?
This place looks like a center for some kind of secret operation.
Perhaps there is useful information to be found regarding the cat mummy.
Are you sure?
It looks just like an A.
Okay.
I-R-I...
Huh?
I
-R?
So I-R is five.
I-R-I-A I-R-I-A So 5-I-A 5-8
T -A 5-8 7 5-8-7 S... I'm gonna trust you guys.
S-O
3 Wait.
5-8-7-3?
I think?
Okay.
There is a lot in here.
Siwa photograph.
Captured after discovering the cat mummy in Siwa.
Junior report!
Henry Walton Jones, Jr.
Henry.
Yeah!
I guess his middle name is Walton.
Recommendation.
Continued surveillance.
Subject seems to have a meddlesome personality.
The orders operation in America left behind traces which led the subject to the Vatican.
We do not know his full intentions yet and should not intervene directly with the subject for risk of attracting unwanted attention.
End report.
No, they're gonna hurt Antonio.
Let's see here.
Mission goal.
Investigate possible connection between the subject's research and his son's excavation in Siwa.
Status resolved.
Oh!
Henry Walton Jones, Sr. After months of on-site surveillance, our operatives have found nothing in the subject's research on the Holy Grail, which could lead to a discovery related to the Reclamation Project.
Furthermore, our own research has found nothing about the Holy Grail that would tie it to the Reclamation Project.
Subject and his son have also been estranged for many years and because of this, we believe it is unlikely that they would be working together.
Their relative proximity to theologically sensitive materials is merely a coincidence of them working in similar fields.
What the hell?
Pup.
Cat.
Pooool.
Alrighty.
Um, well we did that.
Cat, dog, pig.
I don't think it gets me anything though.
Throttle.
Oh wow, I have so many points!
Knock out unaware with a whip pull.
Let's try it.
I like to use my whip on them.
Nice.
8-Bit Romance!
It's my birthday and I'm glad to end it off with your stream.
Thank you for your amazing year of fun and cheer.
Congrats on all your achievements.
May the next one be filled with many more.
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday 8-Bit Romance.
Happy birthday!
Yay.
Alrighty, guys.
So we've done all the field work.
We've gotten the memories, or the mysteries.
Find ancient relics in the Vatican.
Lost artifacts of Europe.
Oh yeah, I got that.
Find medicine bottles.
And field notes.
Wow, there's so much!
Wait, so these are all the things that I didn't complete?
That's crazy!
But I did the field work.
And then we can continue the adventure.
Next time we play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think, like I said, I'm not planning on 100%ing the game.
So I probably will not get all of this.
But that's okay.
So I do want to continue on with the stolen cat mummy.
Those are like collectibles.
You can come back later if you wanted to.
Yeah, I think so.
Surprisingly big game.
I mean, for the price, it better be.
I mean, luckily, I'm using Game Pass.
Interesting.
Wait, where does this lead even?
What the hell?
Yeah, I got it on Game Pass, so...
But still, for the price, it should be a good amount of stuff.
Yeah, thank you guys for joining me for more Indiana Jones.
I want to finish it before I leave.
For Japan.
Hot dog!
I finally have my ATL.
I'd like to thank you and Doki again for the concert.
I'm 100% being real that it's the best VTuber concert I've been.
Thank you.
Between all the performers, the setlist, and the crowd's energy, it's been a vibe.
Thank you!
Happy, happy.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
I'm glad you got back safe.
I got a poster of you and Froggy Wawa from the artist alley.
Froggy Wawa.
Bento, please play MG...
MG Survive is the best play...
Oh!
Survive is the best police special gear game.
Please play the title.
Bento, MGR is bad.
Please don't play the game I like.
Oh, expert.
Thank you.
DMC2 meme, but MG Survive.
Yeah, I know.
Actually, I want to play MG Survive.
One of the guys from the...
Kojima Frequency.
He actually really likes MG Survive.
His name is Fingers.
He's the one who helped me with my...
With music for Freak or Treat.
I wanted to play with him and Barry and Maddy.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
He did the DJ set at MGS Con as well.
His name is Fingers.
I mean, that's his handle.
But I was thinking he could lead us since he knows a lot about the game.
And then we could do like a fun, you know, collab together.
I asked Maddy and she said she would be down for it.
I did not ask Fingers and I didn't ask Barry.
But I think they'd be okay with it, probably.
My ace combat figure from Japan, by the way.
It's kind of messy and broken.
So I hope you don't mind.
What do you mean?
Don't give me your precious ace combat stuff, Nan.
But yeah, Maddy.
I know!
I've always wanted to collab with Maddy.
Have you seen the new version of Solid Snake MGS2 figure?
I have!
Yes, I pre-ordered it this morning.
Lots of people tagged me in it.
So, thank you everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Barry will probably be down.
Probably.
I was just like, who's a bunch of Metal Gear people that I can gather together?
I don't think Maddy has played Survive and I know Barry hasn't played Survive.
So, congratulations for the wonderful concert.
MinkyFuss2024 Thank you, Arararararararagi-san.
Oh, thanks Ghost Orb.
Yeah, Fingers did some pretty cool remixes.
I just want to share what it looks like.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, don't give me that.
Well, earlier you talked about gifting me something.
So, that's why I was like, don't give me your stuff.
Your ace combat stuff.
Mitchisway!
Thanks for 7 months!
Thank you.
Good night, Minky.
Thanks for the stream.
Good night, JMaxx.
I don't remember what else I was gonna say.
Was he the one who DJed for MGSCon 2?
Yeah!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So...
Yeah, I think the game...
Where's the save point?
I think I need to get to a save...
Before I just quit the game.
I know it saved after I did what I did, but...
I'm trapped.
We
were so close.
Oh my god, creating a second hole in Indiana Jones.
Where's the save point?
Thank you guys for the superchats.
Hold on, I'll read them in like 2 seconds.
Once I can get out of here.
Restricted, but I'm in an outfit.
But I'm in uniform.
It didn't turn red, but...
Hold on, I'm just trying to save my game.
You guys, I'm just trying to save my game.
Fast travel to save.
Let's try it.
Nothing.
Oh, it just saved.
Perfect.
Ok.
Yay!
What was that noise?
Just remember, MGS Survive campaign is single player.
The base defense missions are co-op.
I suggest playing the campaign a little bit before co-op.
Thank you, Rendog.
I didn't know that actually.
Oh, the game case cover.
That's right.
Thank you.
Yes, that's right.
You did tell me that.
All I want for Christmas is an eyepatch.
Like my eyepatch?
This one?
Next!
Thanks for the pick!
Really love the concert.
It was awesome being surrounded by fellow fans wearing Doki and Mint and Phantom Thief hoppies.
All cheering for you and Doki.
I'm so proud of how far you both got.
Thank you!
Yeah, I...
I'm really happy with how it turned out.
And how much it seemed everybody enjoyed it.
So...
Big things are in the works.
So, you know, hopefully in the future I can do more concerts.
And, you know, that's also really cool because so many people kind of get the...
You know, I love idols so much.
I love idol culture so much.
Otagi and doing mix and everything.
And, you know, sometimes at concerts, like, you know, like...
Even at like anime conventions, like when a group comes over or something.
Not everybody really knows what to do.
And so it's kind of really fun to see how many more people are being exposed to...
You know, the culture that I've grown up with.
So it's really, really awesome.
And fun learning.
Yeah!
So, we pick up as we go.
You know, as long as you're having fun, that's all there is to it, you know.
It's so fun to be able to go to an idol live and be like...
That's my Oshi and I'm gonna Oshi jump and I'm gonna do calls for her.
I want her to hear my voice.
And feel me giving her so much energy, you know.
It's always fun with Minki.
I'm glad you think so!
Thank you!
Yeah, yeah.
I went to many Otage panels at AWA because of you.
It's funny, like, back long, long ago I used to host my own Otage panels.
And I would get, I don't know, I would get like...
Sometimes I would get a decent number, but usually it would be like 5, 10 people.
So, it's kind of crazy how many people have now gotten into it.
Now the whole room is filled.
I know, right?
You inspired so many people to join in.
Wait, did you change your profile picture?
Is that you, Yuko?
I'm really bad at remembering things, so I do my best to learn calls in Otage so I can cheer you on.
It's all good!
It can get so complicated too.
You know, even if you just know, like, standard mix.
You know, you can still feel like you can join in.
And when you know when to go, oh, hi, when you know when to p-p-p-h, things like that.
It's all, you know...
It's all very formulaic.
Once you know how to do the basics, you can do it to any song, basically.
It's very easy.
I'll try and do, like, Otage mix and stream sometime for people.
Because it can be...
It's all, you know, it can be intimidating, but...
Nani and Ko are inventing new mixes too.
That's how when you know you're in deep.
I used to do that, so...
And I sometimes see the mixes that I've invented, like, passed around sometimes.
And I'm just like, oh, I made that.
But I don't think anybody knows.
Nevermind, I did, I made that.
I won't tell you what, though.
I won't tell you what.
Reminded me all over again why I love live music so much.
Thanks for helping us discover and rediscover the magic.
Yeah, I mean, maybe it feels a little different just because, you know, it's not a band.
We're on a screen, but hopefully I would love to perform with a live band someday.
Let me change profile picture, but it looks the same.
I can't even tell what it is, Nani.
Who is that?
Thanks for concert.
Thanks, Peter Techovs!
Concert was exceptional.
Doobie...
Kingo on stage.
Brought one of my best friends to tears.
Thank you for putting it all together and assembling such an all-star cast.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Live band Minto.
Maybe one day.
I'll work hard to get there.
Did you see?
Kiara wants to be my white girl.
Okay, you guys have to make her dreams come true then, okay?
Thank you!
Yeah, guys have to make her dreams come true.
It's the chant to all-star.
Live band like Miku concerts?
Yeah!
Something like that.
I'm really inspired by a duo named Hime Hina.
One thing though...
One thing that got me so thinking about the concert is...
When I would dance with Doki, it would be so much fun.
When I would dance and sing with her, you know?
It made me just really miss that.
I was just thinking like...
I wish I could have my own dedicated group again, you know?
Kind of feeling...
I've been thinking about it a little bit recently.
But yeah, look up Hime Hina concerts.
They're so great.
Especially when they have the live band and everything.
I don't know.
You and Doki had great chemistry on stage.
I doubt she would want to be...
As...
As intensive as I would want to be.
I apologize to Vito and Everywisp for the super chat earlier.
Yes.
Bread...
Sorry, X-Bread, please go take a nap.
Mint Doki dedicated group.
That's Sam from Death Stranding holding JPEG dog.
Oh my god.
Oh, I see it now.
How do you find these things?
Minto singing Snake Eater with a live band when...
You're the real deal.
I'm not.
It's okay though.
I'll do my best to maybe get there one day.
Okay!
I will see you guys...
When I see you next!
Sorry, I will have a schedule up.
If you're watching the VOD, there will probably be a schedule up.
But I'll have a schedule up.
Thank you guys!
Bye bye everybody!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye!